guys the day's finally come here it is
go to www.dopeasusual.store
and we have the sketchy tee with the
black and white we also have the
pullover sweater
we have shorts and beanies the link will
be in the description of this video or
go to www dot dope as usual dot store
[Music]
i love that song i know you guys are
probably bob in your head too
every every episode guys this is me
right before we start i'm getting hyped
i'm getting ready guys welcome to the
dope as usual podcast i am thomas or
dopez yolo this is marty how are you
guys stop's usual podcast we're here to
talk about you know what let's not do
the intro maybe that's why
youtube's been getting out of this let's
let's just say this this is about life
we're here to talk about unicorns and
rainbows yeah unicorns rainbows and
education
all right and free educate on man i mean
they don't like that that might be
true it might be too political let's
just leave it what's up guys how are you
doing
appreciate you guys being here if you're
in the car please be safe if you're with
your friends or you're by yourself or if
you're at
work in the bathroom hiding so you can
watch this what's up
thank you for giving us your day thank
you for giving us your time it's another
episode guys it's been
so long i don't know how many weeks it's
been we've had so many guests back to
back that we haven't done this
this is my personal favorite thing to do
i love story time
this is more fun to me like it's just
like a one-on-one
friendship hangout time because a lot of
people comment
you know i'm by myself to chill you make
me feel like we're just hanging out good
that is the coolest thing i could have
ever heard i
i love hearing that it's just man when i
moved to work i kicked i was by myself
i had no friends nothing go to school
come home
go to school come home go to work that's
all i did i talked to not a single
person
so if i had this i'd be hyped if i had
something relatable or something that
just entertained me
i'd be stoked so thank you guys for
giving us that feeling thank you for
commenting and letting us know and
speaking of comments
guys youtube thank you so much ready no
you know what button it is
we got it we hit 100 000 on youtube guys
we hit 100 000 subscribers
thank you so much super dope thank you
guys so much for that
i shocked so we started in february man
so
good job good job from scratch ground up
thank you guys so much thank you the
clips channel is about to hit
30k so that is awesome awesome um the
reason i bring that up is because i
wanted to give you guys a little
little snippet a bit of good news
in the month of june for uh the podcast
you guys support so heavy for the month
of june
just the month of june we got over 1.3
million views on youtube by itself no
spotify no nothing that is ridiculous
thank you guys wanna hear something even
crazier you ready
you ready in the month of june guys
watch time minutes
minutes that you guys spent with us
minutes that you guys took out of your
day to come hang out
watch and support like comment whatever
you do
41.4 million
minutes exciting what
what we got our analytics back from
youtube 41.4 million
watch time minutes that means you guys
listen to me
stutter and rent for 41 million
minutes this month this month
thank you this month so guys thank you
so much for that i just wanted to start
off by saying
thank you for supporting also the new
gear is here you got
what it's been two days since it's been
live thank you
we're a hundred orders deep guys thank
you so much for supporting it's
you know when you're planning something
like you have it we can just do this if
we just do this i think it'll pop
it's working so all of us planning
everything we thought of like
just keep going we just keep going we
finally are not in the red anymore we're
finally
starting to make our money back from
putting all the it's just it's a very
good week it's a very good month
thank you guys so much uh let's get on
to my very very very first topic
and it's you know it's about the podcast
so if you're a fan you've already seen
this but i want to
talk about it a little more in depth
like i said earlier
we have had many guests back to back we
haven't had a solo episode so we haven't
been able to
talk you know what i'm saying we can
always talk but we haven't been
just us it has been just us you know
what i'm saying
so let's recap real quick if you haven't
been watching the episodes lately
first guest i want to bring up we had og
one of my best friends you guys saw it
you guys
loved it probably the coolest
the coolest comment section of any
episode
everybody was so hyped let me break it
down for you
og hates being on camera he's camera shy
he has not watched the episode yet
he watches two minutes and goes oh turn
it off bro i want to see it he's so
like oh i hate myself on camera i don't
want to watch my i sound stupid
i don't i messed up right there you
should have cut it he hates it
and not a bad way he just like he just
doesn't like to do it like i don't like
water he doesn't like being on camera
man
and uh he hasn't watched it yet but you
guys thank you so much for supporting
that episode
i want to show him like yo you're funny
just speak forget the cameras are here
just talk
so if you haven't seen that check it out
that's the og episode
what do we call that episode what did we
call it tell us from the hub tales from
the hood thank you so much it was just
two hours of us drinking and talking
about the easter egg game mega stuff it
was fun
um then next guys we had felipe esparza
comedian felipes bars which was
so fun for me he was super cool he was
so cool he came
he came and brought us a bunch of what
was it food things it was so cool
whatever it was i've been looking for
that place i haven't found him
he was so cool he was he was awesome can
we talk about that he hit
the six-foot glass thing twice
we're trying to be chill on youtube i'm
not trying to get too into it like a
giant flower vase yeah yeah yeah yeah
firebase he hit it two times all right i
was shocked he
hit it back to back twice back to back
so
that's why everyone's like yeah he looks
messed up but he was he definitely was
he had it seven seconds before we sat
down so
guys on to the next guest your the
biggest episode yet the biggest episode
yeah the most anticipated one
goblin goblin came i've never met him
before
that guy's awesome he was just
so much [ __ ] fun he was so much fun
man like he
is genuinely raw
and un just a person i don't know i'm
just like he's just
that like the best way possible like
you're unapologetically him yes you are
just you
and i love it so much i had so much fun
filming we're having him back in a
couple months
i had so much fun filming with him i've
never met him before i've watched his
videos so
thank you guys for requesting so much
because that was fun that was one of the
funnest episodes for me by far
uh i was a little messed up i'll say
that not as messed up as him i was
messing with sam but i was i was pretty
drunk
i was pretty drunk by the end of that
but he did pound a bottle of wine of
champagne before we started yeah he was
gone but
like in the best way possible what a fun
episode thank you guys for being there
for that
on to the next episode last week if you
weren't here
if you weren't here and you missed last
week's episode
all right you messed up go back right
now and watch it
we had tommy chong in this building all
right tommy chong came guys
tommy chong sat down and
talked to us which was it was
a special moment in time it truly was
it truly was guys i
like i said i've talked to him before i
did a story time with him it wasn't the
same i was around
eight managers and seven producer things
and
the first thing he said to me when we
sat down the last time was so what are
we
selling today and i go nothing man we're
just talking and he got
hyped he's like oh man all right and he
just started talking to me the last time
i filmed was four hours plus
i only kept 20 minutes of it because
that was story time
so this time he came guys he came with
his managers he was on such a schedule
he just came from doing two shows and he
had to go do another one after
the episode was about hour and a half
long if his managers weren't here and he
had nothing to do
we'd still be talking right now for real
he
how many if you didn't watch it he was
like all right i'm
okay we're done he was trying to chill
he was trying to hang out
man that tommy chong is so damn
cool and insightful and just full of
wisdom and 83 plus years of
knowledge a lot of people don't have a
smart grandfather that's super
successful and iconic to drop knowledge
on them like that well
he i i didn't tell him but i told marty
after
he looks and talks like my grandpa tom
that passed away
so when i was talking to him i was just
like in a trance of
it's like talking to my grandpa again
you know me have those dreams but people
are gone it's like
oh damn that was a dream damn it but
being able to talk to him is just
a trip dude that's exactly how my
grandpa talks like little jokes go
oh ah like this little thing like you
know old man humor man
yeah uh but tommy chong guy that was a
really special moment thank you guys so
much for that
thank you for letting this happen enough
for us to be able to do that that's
very cool highlight of my ear all right
very cool
super awesome tommy chong that is the
last four
uh guests that we've had on the podcast
i just want a little recap all right so
we've been gone for a minute
we haven't seen each other in a while so
what what time we at
9 40.
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh i felt it i felt the 10 minute clock
coming
um for everyone out there 10 o'clock we
like to do it uh to be had to be nice
kids for about 10 minutes and then just
turn into the foot clan from teenage
mutant ninja turtles warehouse and just
you got new cigarettes menthols
irregular yo you know who that was in
that movie
the one that was talking about the the
cigarettes oh no
uh that's the actor the super great
actor what is his name played wild bill
and green mile you ever seen green mile
yeah
he he's the horrible man that they end
up shooting in the chest
same guy i'm i feel like a jerk
i can't bring it up can you bring his
name up i should [ __ ] know this i got
the
ninja turtles lineage going on in my own
household that's true you should know
this what do you want
marbles a regular god that's such a good
movie man uh we're past 10 minutes i'm
lighting this joint i have not smoked
for
bring out the cigarette talk all day all
right i was waiting
i was waiting and i go you know what i'm
gonna just wait again
just so when i smoke this joint it can
be that much better
guys i've decided fully finally sam
rockwell
sam rockwell that's his name what you
want we got marbles
you whatever you want to do do it yeah
sam rockwell 30 years later oscar actor
he is such a good actor man i love that
fool so much
when i first saw him a green mango guy
from teenage mutant channels
because i'm so good with faces yeah
you're a beast for that i feel like
oh my god and you know me i'm just like
i love movies man
i gotta let this join i gotta let this
join and uh oh yeah we have
air now sorry hold on guys there's a fan
in front of me because it's
studio improvements we couldn't have
tommy chong die of heat exhaustion
for real well we wouldn't got silent
fans guys because they go no no no i'm
not having him at two o'clock in the
afternoon during a heat wave
no i'm not gonna be responsible for that
so we've got silent fans
and now i'm just putting them to work so
let's get on to this marty can you uh
bring up those notes guys
let's get right into today's today's
episode
i'm excited i'm really excited to uh
i don't know i don't know what it is i
feel like these are like a
therapy session or something like i'm
talking like
i don't know i don't know what to say
but let's continue here we go guys uh
since this podcast has started since
about two weeks before the podcast i've
had headaches
you guys know that i've talked about it
we haven't seen each other in a while
and i have an update
so i went to this a sinus
a specialist for sinuses got a cat scan
of my head or whatever it is
did the whole machine thing guy comes
back and tells me you have no sinus
infection your sinuses are completely
perfect
you do have a very very bad deviated
septum could be from all the cocaine i
threw into my body
but i don't know that anyways like you
have a super bad deviated septum it's
almost like
non-existent on this side i go ah is
that why
it's always plugged like one side of my
nose is always plugged i have bad
allergies i'm sneezing every five
seconds
my nose is constantly running on one
side
so apparently yes i have a deviated
septum so
he tells me you ready for this i'm at
the doctor this is a couple weeks ago
i'm just like
yeah sinus infection get gone i went
through four rounds of antibiotics guys
four rounds of antibiotics and had to go
to the doctor for my stomach because i
got a damn bacteria infection in my
stomach
this hasn't been fun anyway i'm at the
doctor and he goes you have no sinus
problems
and i thought oh no what does that mean
if it's not sinuses what is it he goes
you don't have a tumor
so i checked behind your eyes i was just
gonna say that little voice from
kindergarten cop came up right it's not
yes exactly exactly dude
but i wasn't in the mood for honor
schwarzenegger quotes i was scared
anyway the guy
tells me you don't have a tumor behind
your head because i have bad eye pain it
feels like someone's sticking
their finger into my eye anyway a little
update
my head was hurting 85 percent of the
day now it's down to like
10. and a few days it didn't even hurt
so it's getting better he tells me you
think i think you have cluster headaches
or tension headaches
he's all your your your muscles and your
head are
contracting so hard it's causing spasms
in your head
that's what he told me he's like if you
stress not sleeping well
not sleeping right could cause all these
things
you guys know my fear needles are you
ready
are you ready for what this man did to
me i felt violated
but good after like i was okay was this
today i haven't heard about this
yeah you have okay yeah
i told you seconds after i launched your
ass to tell you i was all i was
in the parking lot calling you like
you'll never have okay i do around you
remember
yeah you remember so guys i'm
i'm sitting there and he goes okay i'll
go what are the what are the fixes and
he goes
uh you have to have surgery on your
deviant septum it could be causing
you know your sinus headache but your
sinuses are fine
they go okay that doesn't make sense
keep going i'm in beverly hills by the
way i got went to the best
most expensive doctor i could do because
i wanted to make sure
this guy wants his license he's going to
help me like he doesn't want to do
something stupid like in merced
and just you guys know what i'm saying
so i went to a legit doctor
and the first thing i noticed is said
plastic surgeon specialist
sinus specialist i go oh why are you a
plastic surgeon specialist first you
should have said that on your website
jerk i don't want plastic surgery
[ __ ] and i wondered why there was
some
old man with his skin pulled back all
tight walking out of the room with
bad sinuses especially after the
invisalign
incident you're probably extra cautious
well
the viz line was worse this is scarier
than my teeth getting solid
i know some of you at home with scarier
so
i'm sitting there you go so cortisone i
go okay cortisone that's a shot he goes
so i can give you a shot in your head
no no [ __ ] thank you no thanks he
goes
it's going to help it's um it will work
immediately like oh
uh i have a fear of needles man i really
rosie's not there with me all right
rosie did not come with me so it was
even worse
and as he's getting this needle out he
grabs this thing it looks like white
milk and starts his cortisone i guess
and he starts
drawing it back and i'm telling him uh
no
like i i really rather not i have a fear
of needles and i might pass
out in your chair if you stick that in
my head and then
and he goes well this is really going to
help trust me and he starts going
i have a fear of needles i have almost
passed out and i am a doctor
so trust me i feel you and i went all
right this old man is
kind of calming me down gotcha walks
behind me
and i go so where exactly are you going
to put
and i don't say yes i didn't agree i
didn't say
go ahead i didn't say i'm ready as the
man's behind me
he just walks up on me and sticks me in
the [ __ ] temple
no words just goes go so you're almost
done you're almost done bam
puts a little cotton swab goes wasn't
that easy and i go that might have been
the best shot i've ever had in my life
because i know it's the anticipation
that makes you pass out i've passed out
before
because i have a fear of needles too i
looked at like
[ __ ] you first first off [ __ ] you for
doing that to me but second
thank you for letting me know like so
that's what i gotta do huh
all right just do it don't i'm not gonna
look that full stuck a needle into my
temple guys into my [ __ ] i don't know
how i feel about that
it scared the [ __ ] out of me i thought
is my brain close
yeah no the temple is where you die i
mean he hits you with the [ __ ] pulp
fiction
guys i was i was in the middle of going
so where exactly are you gonna
and i stood still oh he goes don't move
don't move done three seconds deep
done he was done gone he just and i felt
it go
into my hand away about 15 minutes later
my headache stopped though
so it did help but that was about a
month and a half ago my headaches are
coming back a little
but i'm like i'm saying 10 of what it
used to be man
when it was 85 now it's 10. nice but uh
that's my another doctor's story why is
it every time i go to the doctor
something happens to me
i mean it wasn't a brain tumor so that's
good [ __ ] hope not i [ __ ] hope not
you did all the cat scans and all that
my sign is just still getting deeper
i mean if the shot if the shot made it
feel better shot help and i noticed when
i start getting like
aggravated as [ __ ] when i start like my
head start like [ __ ]
i start getting like a twitch in my head
and it
really hurts man it hurts so [ __ ] bad
sometimes it feels like it's in my brain
in the middle so i still need to go to
the doctor it does hurt it does hurt
but uh that's my story from the doctor
guys
i updated you now the fans give a [ __ ]
yeah there's people always hit me up
with science effects check this out try
this this this i get dms every day i'm
like [ __ ] yeah thank you
not a science infection guys so cocaine
deviated septum so here we go
4.1 there it is that's what happened
so let's move on
to another topic sorry
guys i'm talking about the news a little
bit fourth of july
i do [ __ ] oh gee loves fireworks went
og's at night
hung out for two hours and left
sorry um set off some tnt and [ __ ] that
i don't like those fireworks um
something that happened on 4th of july
it's in the news i wanted to bring it up
because it's just crazy i was talking i
was talking to you about it
why are you laughing oh because what i
said
don't i don't know if i want to say it
on the air like that i don't know
i don't know man don't laugh about it
it's so sad
but okay i'll say it columbus blue
jackets it's a hockey team all right you
guys ready for this
on fourth of july his name is matisse
kival i i'm not gonna even try he's a
hockey player
okay and he's not a mighty duck
obviously because i can't say his name
this guy was in a hot tub right i
thought it was at his house he's at his
coach's house they're all having a party
fourth of july
he's in a hot tub he's the goalie of the
team
in a hot tub guys somebody next door
lights off a mortar more like the
fireworks that shoot bro it
malfunctioned went sideways into their
yard and hit the full
in the chest and killed him could you
imagine being a hot tub with your friend
you hear
and your friend's chest pops open
i'll be so i would i'd i know it's an
accident man
some final destination it's fine i do
you kill the person that did it
do they go to jail for murder i think
they have to manslaughter jail time i
mean you
killed somebody that's like reckless
it's reckless endangerment with bodily
harm review
fatality all i know is i read the
article this guy tried to get out of the
way
he tried to get out of the hot tub and
as he got out it popped him in the chest
and
killed him a firework super [ __ ] sad
and the reason marty laughed when i
brought it up because it's not funny
but it is funny okay look it it's very
[ __ ] sad the man
is dead his family's mourning right now
i'm an [ __ ] okay i'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i made a little slight joke
in my head and i went
i brought this up at dinner all right
last night with all my homies and i go i
told them they and i went
i was like give you guys like 30 seconds
nobody's gonna say it i go man am i the
only funny [ __ ] here
but also the only piece of [ __ ]
he blocked it i'm sorry bro he's a
goalie
he got up out of the way dove and still
blocked it
his instincts kicked in so hard he
probably saved somebody's life
he probably saved some multiple people
from getting skull like scorched
but that was my joke i went nobody's
gonna make the joke that he's a goalie
and he blocked
the firework he saw something went oh
[ __ ] i gotta block that [ __ ]
that's what's funny to me it's sad as
[ __ ]
still but in like maybe like two years
i'll be
like jesus make a joke about it i
thought it was a good joke i thought it
was funny like no
when you said that earlier when i walked
in so casually i'm like oh he is a
[ __ ] comic all right
like that was bad i feel bad for saying
it i'm sorry
for all you families out there i am
sorry but that is [ __ ]
hysterical it's [ __ ]
comedy bro come on if this was a sick if
this is desperate housewives
and they had this scene in there you're
like yo that was [ __ ] fantastic
but no it's real life and it's sad but
look on the f no there's no fried side
okay i'm a dick let's move on i'm just
trying to piece yeah
the little dude inside your head just
has no too soon filter
i know mine's the same way the thing is
like
i don't like to say him because i don't
like people i don't even [ __ ]
like hurting animals bro i don't eat
meat i don't like punching people i
don't want to hurt
anyone that's still funny to me
i'm a piece of [ __ ] at heart i think
horrible offensive
uh anthony jeselnik's one of my favorite
comedians because he's such
a piece of [ __ ] like in a good way like
a
human you want to chill do you want to
hang out for the rest of my life unless
i need that
in my life like [ __ ]
that's the reaction i want from my
friends because usually it's me and i go
sorry guys i'm sorry i'm sorry
didn't you think uh-huh you're
apologizing i'm apologizing
i'm sorry i can make a joke at anything
and i feel so bad about it
i feel so [ __ ] bad when my uncle john
was sick
after i like he told me he had cancer
and all that [ __ ] after about 20
minutes of me being like sad i went that
fool's gonna have some good cancer jokes
bro
because he's a fool he was such a
[ __ ] idiot and so funny he's anthony
just like
times 10. like the [ __ ] he says i go
stop
write it down [ __ ] i don't give
a [ __ ] like i know you don't care
write it down for me because i was
[ __ ] buddy my whole life my whole
life i knew
i was 10 i was 30. and
even he like i would have to apologize
for him a lot
around people i don't even know why i
brought that up right or how
why did i bring oh i was waiting for his
cancer jokes
i couldn't wait for him to be like all
like at home like getting better and
making
making jokes about being like oh pick
that up i have [ __ ] cancer
pick it up for me okay there's so many
things he would use just to
come on i have cancer let me get the
[ __ ] weed man come on i couldn't i
can't
i was like very excited for that only
that's the only thing i was like
the only good thing about this there's
gonna be some good comedy some good
[ __ ] funny [ __ ] this man is gonna be
saying
when he's trying to get his weight back
and like all the stupid [ __ ] he says
my uncle would just go around and say
the dumbest [ __ ]
like we'd be in the store and he just my
mom's dead
loud as [ __ ] and just keep walking and
you can see people like what the
[ __ ] john why i don't know
like all right that's a good answer just
to [ __ ] with people
just to [ __ ] with people and to make us
laugh i don't know how many times he
said like i just want to see you left
i just said i just wanted to see you
crack the [ __ ] up that was like
his pastime sport was to make us laugh
and he did
i do that with uh to april like
yes yes dude she'll be ordering through
the drive-through and i'll start [ __ ]
punching her in the stomach and [ __ ]
while she's talking not punched like
poking
poking in the stomach tickling her
so she couldn't hear right this was her
i started [ __ ] just
elbow punching her rabbit punching her
in the chest while she was pregnant with
her last daughter
she's been crying i'm sure you're
talking to like an insurance company and
she'll be wrapping up the call and
they'll be like all right have a great
day and i'll be like i love you
and then they hang up the kids
yo uh marty when i [ __ ] facetime him
and i
know i know your evil face
i'm gonna assume those are fireworks oh
fire i thought someone's on the roof
i'm so paranoid man i thought someone's
about to jump into like a [ __ ] ninja
through the bars right now
in your mind there's tweakers everywhere
there's always tweakers everywhere man
and there's always the crow somewhere
but he's not
for the good all right that's like i'm
like [ __ ]
you know what [ __ ] me up dude was lost
boys you ever seen lost boys the vampire
movie
i looked it up from one of your
references on the podcast
yeah so when the vampire if you for all
you have to see him when he bites that
bald man in the head and lifts him into
the sky
that's why i always thought it was gonna
happen to me like oh no no i can't do it
so when i go take the trash out of my
grandma grace is in the
country it's just i'm staring at the
[ __ ] midnight sky and running back
i still run back to my house i'm [ __ ]
in my 30s uh-huh i still go
ugh you gotta run back in my mom's house
in the country
the country's scary yeah the country's
scared my mom starts i took the trash
out a couple weeks ago when i was there
and the whole time i walked backwards
back to the house i'm not [ __ ]
kidding
this was [ __ ] five episodes ago i
still go [ __ ] kiefer sutherland
it's gonna bite the [ __ ] out of me
somewhere i just it's scary it's scary
why did we get off topic oh your evil
[ __ ] smile
i know when this fool when i call him
and he's got this little smile what the
[ __ ] did you say april
well no i was just so you know bust down
for the whole
so for the past 38 minutes i've been
talking [ __ ] to april and she's been
talking [ __ ] to me and you hear
nah [ __ ] in the background and
it's always something ridiculous but
funny
yeah i mean let's put this out there to
the fans so the last time
listen i can't wear jewelry i just
don't i can't wear it this was the last
thing
she had the audacity to be like call
thomas call thomas hold on
marty you were shit-faced too marty
doesn't drink a lot
as soon as he answered marty you're
drunk
i was in the picture if you feel okay
post it in the thing i've screenshotted
the facetime because marty's in the back
[Laughter]
oh i was celebrating one of these
goddamn episodes yeah
yeah something it was something but yeah
i was she was trying to
i can't wear a wedding ring i just can't
like i can't have things out
for 10 years don't wear a ring yeah but
the wedding ring i have was my dad's
wedding ring
so it's like a special thing and like it
falls off sometimes and [ __ ] it fell off
i couldn't find it one time after that i
was like i already hate wearing this
thing i'm constantly [ __ ] with it
and then she's like when we were in
hawaii she's like all right like
you get the tattoo then i'm like do you
know how bad that would hurt on your
[ __ ] knuckles you have your final
armor
that's what you're saying no it is the
whole left arm is
done
no just right here yeah i know i'll
that's probably the route i'm going to
end up going needles
i'm like it's not 1950. we don't do this
anymore it's just different she doesn't
understand that
so i don't know maybe somebody out there
could back me up but i just can't wear
jewelry i'm not and cannot wear jewelry
i can't [ __ ] do it i can't do it i
wish i could
i wish i could the only thing i could
ever wear in my life
it's a fat cuban chain with diamonds on
it and not on me
i just like the way it looks you see
what i'm saying like i just want to take
pictures of it god that's a nice ass
other than that that's it i love because
my homies had a cuban with it's
completely flooded and it's
i didn't know when future was like you
can't even see my diamond i was like
this motherfucker's on cody
there's some diamonds that you're
looking like [ __ ]
it's like staring into the sun my homie
john's changed so
stupid when i look down like
we're so privileged like once you start
making money
can you even wear that like oh yeah he
could wear that hmm
yeah he could wear it i'm already so
[ __ ] paranoid i put something like
that on i'm like oh when he when he
first got you he told me he's like i
don't have security wearing this [ __ ]
oh yeah bro that's a couple of rags on
your neck yeah at that point you might
as well have
it security what the [ __ ] is oh
fireworks we establish that okay
did you know for everyone else you can
get your diamonds insured so if you get
a super ball or a chain
get insured someone rips off your nickel
thanks
and all you do now is have clean money
when you get it back from jared's
i don't know my homie's gotta get all of
it insured but uh
i can't wear a ring dude i can't wear a
[ __ ] ring
og pulls off that goddamn pinky ring a
pinky ring
yeah he bought that [ __ ] a couple years
ago i remember when he bought it and he
lost it for like eight months and told
nobody
and then somebody in his family found
outside the lawn bro i didn't want to
tell nobody
i felt embarrassed that i lost it like
yo if you would have asked she's like
bro
i know it's yours i've had it for
[ __ ] months
so you lost that [ __ ] i can't wear
jewelry guys i will lose it i wear a
watch one time when i graduated high
school because my aunt gave it to me
as a present 30 minutes before i
graduated i go oh
look i have to wear it i kept it because
my aunt gave it to me but i can't wear
watches i can't wear jewelry i have a
space jam watch bomb ass space jam watch
it's like it's bomb as [ __ ] it's got
michael jordan tasmanian devil and bug
might be worth something no i bought it
like five years ago all right that's the
only watch out
all right it's a space jam watch i've
worn it like five times so [ __ ]
baller
last watch i had was the g-shocks
remember those i thought i was [ __ ]
doing something with it i went
my brother was in jail and [ __ ] i went
up there at the g-shock and [ __ ]
[ __ ] showing it off with the navy
blue
[Laughter]
oh no dude oh my god we get off track so
bad sorry guys sorry
sorry i can't wear jewelry i might get
the tattoo
on my finger and i hate tattoos
see i got a dilemma because i got a big
ass portrait of my first daughter that
takes out my whole forearm so you have
to get the other two i got two more kids
you better get them i got april yeah i
got hella freckles everywhere i don't
know
freckles will [ __ ] your portrait up
since that's freckles you should connect
them like [ __ ]
constellations and make faces oh yeah
emery that
box that's your constellation that's for
you
yo your [ __ ] kids are tired uh
sorry we got way off course no rank for
me can't do it
all right so it's [ __ ] subtle i have
to get a tattoo i've never had a tattoo
and i get one you know the only tattoo i
wanted when i was a kid
no lie i wanted it for like 10 years
from when i was like four
to about 15. packers logo no
i'm such a [ __ ] idiot
i wanted a picture from behind the head
of an oompa loompa
[ __ ] fighting another one to the
death with willy wonka with money
standing in front of him like that like
don king [ __ ]
yeah your face was my face after i why
the [ __ ] would you get that on your body
still a cool picture at what point did
that thought pop into your head though i
was watching willy wonka
don't be a really cool man like you know
like one
over here another one fighting on the
side willy wonka like that with money
like
betting on them i was five four why the
[ __ ] did that come into my head
dumbest [ __ ] i ever thought of so glad i
didn't get it
could you imagine that on my butt oh my
just a full back piece
a full piece of [ __ ]
just stupidity yo that's a real thing
that was real i've really wanted it it's
a sick idea i want to make that [ __ ] in
photoshop it'd be a funny picture
right like just like a meme like yeah
and these two of
us like the all right here we go you
know why i mixed it together
it's the back scene from when street
fighter starting
remember street fighter and the guy's
behind him he goes
and the guy falls and it goes up to the
buildings that scene from like slightly
behind the head
is how i wanted it that's why that's why
i wanted the willy wonka now i remember
it was street fighter
opening characters and [ __ ]
my brain man pisses me off
it remembers some [ __ ] though it
remembers a lot
almost all and that's you know how
frustrating is to have to remember
everything
yeah my [ __ ] tapped out about five years
ago i'm on limited storage i remember
the important things
yeah you know what it is i think i
remember a lot better before i started
doing mass amounts of drugs too
because i can't remember my 20s very
well i mean i can
of course but i can't remember like
oh then i did this this this then i did
that but no but i was also selling drugs
and just living so there was no time
limit as soon as i stopped going to
school probably
i was on a limit a time and like a
schedule brain my aim's the big haze
yeah it got hazier i could still
remember specific down to the [ __ ]
number
if you ask about it but i couldn't just
blurt
well i could i could i'm [ __ ]
tripping
story time yeah time i feel like i can't
remember everything all right
um off topic let's get back on topic
jesus i'm very sorry to the family of
the man who's monkey all right
i'm sorry marty if you would have
started laughing at the [ __ ] second i
started talking about it
i wouldn't even brought it up but it had
to be said
i'm sorry and that's why he said that my
brain's dick i'm very sorry okay
but it's i mean technically it's
we're here to comment on things that
happen he's batting a thousand right
that's i mean technically i'm a for
listen you're looking at a former
ice hockey goalie here okay i'm allowed
to comment hockey oh yeah that was
the first word i played that's funny all
right
i'm sorry okay okay okay all right
i'll leave it at that i'm sorry guys i'm
sorry if you're that's a fan still super
sad
super sad on to the next thing how about
one last
note on that you know what the sabers we
had the last i don't know if that was
the last goalie
who's the [ __ ] sabres i don't watch
hockey it's the buffalo sabers that's
our hockey team oh i don't know
man why aren't they the buffalo
buffaloes man
there's no buffalo i mean [ __ ] we got
the bills
which i always say is ironic because
most people have a hard time paying the
[ __ ] bills in buffalo and [ __ ]
we got the sabres who i thought was the
savers till i was like 10
because you know that makes more sense
than the sabers but
yeah we had clint milarchuk i think was
his name and he got his throat
sliced that's the guy yeah oh i've seen
that i've seen that clip
this is disgusting he didn't die i don't
think i don't know
but that's when they invented those
throat guards disgusting i remember them
telling me that when i was getting my
equipment and [ __ ]
this is why you got to wear the throat
guard because homeboy got his [ __ ]
throat sliced open on the ice
well i didn't win a lot but i am i did
set a a league record
what was that i'm the only guy that took
my skate off and tried to stab somebody
with it i love happy gilmore
i [ __ ] love yo actually no i remember
as i was falling asleep last night i was
thinking
about adam sandler sitting right here
and i thought
are you going to be able to handle
yourself tom
oh i thought you were about to be on
some like talking to him like that in
your journey no like are you gonna be
no i was supposed to be able to handle
this [ __ ] when i go to sleep i it
doesn't just
doesn't i wish i could just fall asleep
but i think of
you guys know in movies when they go
what did you do last night it's like a
blackout drunk scene and they go and
they follow they go
and they think what did they think it
was and it goes to what they really were
doing
like in wolf of wall street when he
makes it home yes yes this is
this is but you know when they like [ __ ]
like the camera's just on a person it
just
and there's like fast forwards and
there's like tweakers and movies and
they're just
it just shows what they were doing with
a still camera and just they're going
back and forth back and forth yeah like
hyperlapse that hyperlapse
my brain does that so every movie i
watch to do that
so that's why i get bored of movies fast
unless they're super funny
because i can watch the whole thing
right now my head fast forward
[Music]
boring right so the reason i said that
oh my god why the [ __ ] did i bring that
up
adam sandler so last night i was falling
asleep and my brain was going
i was seeing myself getting out of the
car come on get ready come in here you
said
that
i can i know internally and like outward
i'm fine where the [ __ ] do i start
inside yeah
i might even shed a tear i don't know
what to do
it's if there's one person in life
that's shaped my whole existence as that
guy
everything since my moment my mom showed
me billy madison and played it she goes
this is really fun oh my
pepper and i go
shampoo who's this guy condition oh my
god who is this [ __ ] guy then he's
doing the [ __ ]
at the table he's talking [ __ ] to eric
that i blew my mind
and my mom's sitting there watching with
me and then for no reason he just
culture club comes on he starts doing
the dance on the [ __ ] stairs
and i go wait that's boy george my mom
listens to boy george all the time
who's this guy it's the first thing i
ever saw he's probably the first
personality where you're like oh you can
be funny and goofy
it's okay yes yes
yeah you're right you're right because i
didn't watch funny [ __ ] as a kid i think
i wanted to watch cartoons well that
whole
that whole that whole arrow was just
beginning then though like
yeah those legends of that genre were
just starting to roll out really
truly and i always feel weird and always
leave a comment man leave a comment if
you feel this way
because i'm i told rosie
last night there's nothing in the planet
i love more i don't care about drugs i
don't care about food i don't care about
water
besides rosie there's nothing on the
planet that makes me more
stoked in movies we watch fools rush in
last night with [ __ ] selma hike and
chandler whatever his [ __ ] matthew perry
and as i'm watching i'm just reminiscing
on every single [ __ ] scene
because i watched that for the first
time my grandma's on sixth stream i can
remember exactly what was happening when
i saw it
and what i was doing when i watched it
for the first time and the times i used
to repeat the movie over and over and
over and over
you know what i'm saying like it unlocks
some memories that i had about sitting
on that brown [ __ ] car billy
it just so my earliest
love of a person was that full so when i
was falling asleep i know it was a long
ass rant so i was falling asleep last
night i thought
so when i'm opening the door and his
manager is like oh we're pulling up and
i move in and he comes in what the
[ __ ] do i do like i know i'm gonna
handle myself it's gonna be
great i've never
had i've never had that problem like
[Music]
that level of a challenge or like what
would you say
something so significant together when i
saw brett favre my heart went
oh my [ __ ] god then he dissed me i
went
[ __ ] you so even if adam sandler was a
[ __ ] dick i'd be like
i still love the [ __ ] out of you your
piece of [ __ ] i still love the [ __ ]
everybody i know he's not a mean guy
to me though can't be me what you're
doing in that moment is super powerful
like laying there visualizing things oh
yeah i do that all the [ __ ] time i
did it for this place i did it for
everything i did it for
i do for everything yeah i can run back
every picture i ever posted yeah
just as i was making it and just going
through what i was thinking about before
i did it
it's it's movie that's why i want to
interview kevin smith so bad he's a
great director man
he really puts my ultimate goal in life
is to be an old ass man directing things
or jimmy kimmel chair type of thing
because i never thought i'd like it but
it's easy for me it's easy and it makes
me stoked that i know people are stoked
as [ __ ] yeah that's the biggest that's
the biggest thing for me like
that's what makes me happiest knowing
that people are stoked
so few people get to have that like it's
super special that's what i'm so
just grateful for this situation because
i mean i've been a part of that before
but not like this
it's a whole different thing it's not
just my show this is our show that's why
i never say my
podcast it's always our podcast i mean
it's our [ __ ]
it's different man it's different um
so as i'm laying there and thinking [ __ ]
hold it together will you smoke like i
don't know it sounds like some weirdo
[ __ ] but it's
truly not as a kid i was that was who i
looked up to my whole life
there was never it's never changed so
it's as long as i can remember
so there's a fine line between going
into that for two and a half hours
versus like pulling out a bunch of like
how you did with tommy like a bunch of
stuff we
people hadn't really heard before or
like does tommy chong i mean i can
remember him just as long as adam sailor
and i know my mom she'll let me be
watching nice dreams and [ __ ] as a kid
but i was and i remember thinking
i thought people that drugs were losers
and i never thought that cheech and
charm were losers
because they were funny and i could see
everybody in the room laughing and i
didn't get some of the jokes
you know i mean when i was a kid and
tommy chong was in the
back of the van i think it was up in
smoke with two chicks and he wasn't
banging him he just like i think got a
zipper stuck or
i can't remember what happens they get
stuck and they're moving and everyone
else thinks he's banging two chicks
and then i just remember my mom died
laugh and i just go why is that so funny
and then i got older
oh that's why but i remember my mom
laughing at me thinking
all right i want to make them laugh
that's what they're doing and then to
see the man just sitting here
and us actually be like yo you're cool
he's like yeah let's chill let's hang
out and talk
because he was even after the cameras
are off what a [ __ ] awesome dude
to him that was like that's like life
goals to me though for somebody to
be so famous for so long have made so
much money
of all the connections good royal
treatment everywhere he goes for the
past 40 years for him to sit down and be
like
what makes me happy my wife my family
spreading the word of all this stuff
like that was just like he had those
vibes radiating off on him that's that's
last time that's what he told me too
because it's like the thing that makes
me happy my wife and i'm like damn this
will don't change
he's truly that might be the happiest
guy of all time and i would have thought
he was like
60 if i didn't know better oh bro he's
family or 84 years old yeah
doesn't look like it no at all no
came in just a g like cool as [ __ ] sarah
donna got to it so
yeah man i hope that we've had so many
guests that i'm like damn they need to
be a recurring guest
damn i could see up to coming right down
the pipe with that one
yep he was great because they all bring
different vibes like look at i mean [ __ ]
look at the
the difference between goblin and tommy
like
completely different yeah but that's the
whole point i watched
i watched back episode one because i had
a
i had a story i'm gonna bring up today
and i didn't want to repeat myself so i
had to make sure it wasn't in there
and watching it one of the things i said
even though a couple months ago i don't
[ __ ] remember everything i say
i mean like i was just talking
one of the things i say is i want to
bring different elements of all snacks
it can be like this is a ufc podcast
well this is about the movies like [ __ ]
off i want to interview kevin smith like
i said
what a [ __ ] director what a lifelong
cult classics like i
always told rosie when i said i just
need that one cult classic and i could
be
[ __ ] happy for wrestlemania i need
that one the one that makes
people at home people that watch go oh
and they see the shirt and public go
oh my god that fool likes oh good [ __ ]
you know i mean when you see someone
with a true romance shirt it's a move
have you ever seen it true romance with
michael rapper
yeah before yeah exactly great movie but
if you see someone with a true romance
shirt
or something obscure movie to have a
shirt of
we would probably be friends and that's
why you made friends as a kid so well
oh nice batman shirt i [ __ ] love
batman
we're homies if you can find something
you can relate to
like it's instant that you know we might
be friends
you know i mean how many times you go
that guy's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and he likes that i thought he was gonna
be cool he likes the same [ __ ] bands
i do like no he's a piece of [ __ ]
well i guess that's rare because you
expect to like somebody because if
they're like
you unless you're a [ __ ] narcissistic
weird [ __ ]
especially podcasts cause they're so
specific
yeah dude so the reason i said that is
because
god i ran so hard my conversation's back
right here and i'm over here already but
the reason i said that is uh i just want
to bring different
forms of life and i mean like i want to
bring
everything i want to bring in i told you
i want to bring a financial advisor
like a [ __ ] bomb ass one like a super
well
spoken financial advisor and go hey man
how the [ __ ] should i handle my money
because people that watch
that's knowledge that we should be
having that's great
if it's an hour long it's cool and i'm
sitting here smoking [ __ ] joints
asking this guy about his life and going
all right cool let's get down to
business
how should i do my taxes so we can all
be like you know good and not go to jail
what should i do how should i write this
off so what you're gonna wanna do is
this this this this what should they
teach kids in high school
so they don't [ __ ] up their credit and
ruin their lives when they're 18.
thank you thank you [ __ ] just like that
like [ __ ] we should learn in school
because there's people right now
watching that are in college but there's
also people that are watching
shout out scott that are in [ __ ] 60s
so
like we don't have to just go well
here's a rapper soundcloud rapper for
all the guys that are under 20.
no no we don't have to do we have to
just go here for lanes and lanes no
that's the
that's the title of a strong host is
being able to talk to anybody
and have a fun interesting conversation
i mean that's the whole point
yes like i i always i also was imagining
i won't say what rapper and i was
thinking oh what if he was a dick like
you know i tell him get the [ __ ] out
like instantly there's nobody in the
planet that i'm gonna just like
and i'm not saying people are mean i'm
saying my brain was just going crazy
last night for [ __ ]
hours just thinking of all these things
every case scenario could happen
that's how i think of all the time i
think of with everything
anywhere i go that's why i have to have
my way out of a room i can't just be in
a [ __ ] building i got to know what's
going on
um like i have to have this reward yeah
every single thing has to have a [ __ ]
plan for me in my head and i could be
doing it
while i'm walking up to you and going
all right phone two three four really
cool i'm good
five exits you're gonna be like i could
be as i'm shaking your hand like all
right cool
done but
yeah my brain just keeps going sorry for
the [ __ ] long rant sorry guys
you know what this is what podcasters
are all about though that's what the
podcast is about man
i was just going we got [ __ ] what's
going on we're at the the rant city
uh grand city merch coming soon france
city guys here's another
episode full of rant city and we went
off
anyway i am saying i [ __ ] love your
ass i want to high-five the [ __ ] out of
you
and then me you and marty play 21 and
horse [ __ ] yeah cause he's
he's good at basketball man he's good i
could dribble good
and that's it that's it this full is
batting a thousand
yeah right what was your record what's
your record what is it a thousand
thousand marty shot once and hit it
you god damn right all right he's got
the best record in his whole state all
right
we're talking college here yeah college
basketball came off a clean screen
is that the picture that you posted no
that was different could you imagine the
only shot you ever
made or a choke that was different they
got a picture of it the place went
[ __ ] nuts though
[Laughter]
boom we were blowing the other team out
that's why i was in
didn't matter
you got a scholarship i thought i was a
freshman
oh that's why you don't play a lot yeah
i was on a team of grown men i was a 17
year old white boy we had
35 year old dudes from the [ __ ] all
over the world on our team got you
yo i still have dreams man where i'll be
playing football again
ugh that's such a bad thing to leave
behind
[ __ ] you yeah i won't even say his name
my coach man in high school really
ruined my whole
experience he made me quit football how
you such a piece of [ __ ] i just couldn't
take it
i still have dreams about that [ __ ] i
have i had a dream recently where i was
playing for the [ __ ] 49ers
and we were going out to the stadium i
thought
i can't wait to crack somebody that's
all i kept thinking that we went out and
i
saw all the crowd thought like like
could you imagine being out there
playing
[ __ ] football in front of all those
people cracking somebody mm-hmm
that's the one thing i regret my life is
[ __ ] football it's just quitting
but my life be different so i couldn't
go back it's also butterfly effect [ __ ]
all right
sorry this [ __ ] podcast is getting
all crazy here we go let's get back on
topic
damn why are we just having a [ __ ]
high conversation in the garage right
now
i'm sorry guys i'm very very sorry here
we go let's get back
more news one more piece of news all
right
shikari richardson have you seen this
yeah i've never seen a bunch of
a million [ __ ] times bro i just saw
it
i watch the news i don't watch anything
i just get online get the [ __ ] off
so this girl is an american right
she's a track star and she tested
positive for thc
so she can't [ __ ] run they announced
that today she's
out so
why that's just
my question why why can't she go because
she has thc did michael phelps testbot
and
wheat just blatant like tardation on my
i have no idea what the answer would be
for that because i mean
it's just because it's in tokyo [ __ ]
i'm what are like the stipulations of
no thc because i was a kid the
snowboarder got his gold medal taken
away
because he tested positive for teachers
it can't be based in logic obviously it
has to be based in some like old school
tradition law where they chop your hand
off over
weed or some [ __ ] i have no [ __ ]
clothes because i just saw it and it
says will not run and thought
[ __ ] could you imagine what
she's going through right now
she's probably got way more famous than
she would have if she would have ran
when you're an athlete man fame is cool
but yeah it's the olympics dude it's the
olympics and you only get this prime
you only get those four years in your
life oh yeah be 24
to being 28 it's cool but you never get
that
i [ __ ] killed i was 24. always i
killed those 29
20 [ __ ] eight or however long i think
it's [ __ ] stupid and i think it's
like
somebody dedicates their life to that
and it's like oh technicality
sorry also she needs to come out with
her own strain now because
yeah that's what i'm saying like it
might turn out that she needs to come
out of their own
people don't even care like how many i
mean people watching olympics but i mean
paul pierce is out here posting stories
of weed farms all right guys
the [ __ ] truth god sorry post
weed farms marty how [ __ ] long have
we been filming
53. oh that's not bad we've ranted for
only 25 minutes
shout out to paul pierce throughout the
paul pierce not a sports show
all right trying to get that season two
marty helped film that [ __ ]
show guys
very cool when you text me i'm filming
with shannon sharp today go get the [ __ ]
daddy that [ __ ] was crazy
shannon shark how big was his head he
was built like a
greek god oh [ __ ] the other athletes
weren't like him he was the
oldest yeah he's just the most
disciplined still
he's the one that as i was walking
behind him filming i'm like oh this
dude's a
[ __ ] athlete even we had other big
time athletes but he was the one that
looked like it and he's [ __ ] 50-plus
years old probably
yeah well i mean he talked about his
discipline and [ __ ] he's like i've been
in the same routine for the past [ __ ]
40 years like i do the same thing
really yeah he's like his i mean he's
just a g like he's just by the book real
quick you said he pulled up in a regular
car and all the younger guys pulled up
and [ __ ] cullinans
yeah i mean he had like an escalade or
some [ __ ] but it was like an older one
or whatever and he was talking about
like i had that car i barely got any
miles on it i don't go anywhere like i
ben had that car
and then the next dude pulled up in like
a [ __ ] culinary door yeah that was
truck yep i love that car man man i was
i was b-rolling the [ __ ] out of them
pulling in you could imagine
it's such a bummer homie's got one it's
so murdered out
yeah i get it oh that's what he has oh
okay yeah i can get it now
yeah i get it for that i mean that's
like a half a mil but i mean
yeah but uh yeah shout out pop here the
paul was the funniest one though paul
was one he was like i gotta see a lot of
behind the scenes ones the stuff you had
to cut out for tv was funny
yeah very funny yeah and it directly
coincided with his little
espn controversy and [ __ ] right when the
episode came out i was editing all the
footage that was very yeah
ironically told me he's like i'm editing
the footage he goes whoa we have to cut
this out and go was that bad
that's not bad that's funny like that's
he's an athlete that's funny
and then he gets in trouble two days
later as marty's editing what he's
supposed to cut out like
i pull up on worldstar and it's him with
all these strippers and [ __ ] i was like
oh we're not leaking any information
don't get married in trouble guys
nothing like that because obviously
we're just out there it's out there yeah
but
when it was happening like some insider
stuff right here wow
wow this fool's getting in trouble now
but anyway shout out to paul pierce's
weed farms
shakari richardson i'm sorry from saying
it wrong that's kind of a wild name
yeah it's split yeah i guess so i mean
sure
that's kind of cool but it's [ __ ] up
for her anytime you dedicate your life
it's like she looks young as hell yeah
yeah that's
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm sorry um
anyway that was my other piece of news
guys i have to get back
on track i i am high i'm going to say
that right now marty
i can feel it and this air i have the
sign on the fan it's just
uh-huh nice it's putting me into a daze
where do you got going in the joint over
there
uh the joint this is
cannabis brothers
ah cookie cam it's from the cannabis
brothers all right
check it out yeah this is my homies
cannabis brothers this it's the chem
cookies chem cookies camo cookies
i don't know what it is i'm just [ __ ]
high i don't say that often but i am
let's get back on track okay here comes
another
what's good segment
[Laughter]
we're getting these sound effects dialed
in it really scared me that one's there
to scare people
do it again ew that scared the [ __ ] out
of me
because i knew i wasn't speaking i'm
looking at you you're not talking that
scared me oh yeah
no more of that that's there to creep
out guests
god i loved using butt as a kid uh
segment of what's good
are you ready marty i haven't shown you
this yet you just saw the notes
are you ready for an uh uh segment of
what's good here we go
this is a segment that's cool stuff
people doing good deeds
super cool new inventions i don't know
whatever cool stuff
what's good what that's what the [ __ ]
segment's called all right here we go
god i'm so [ __ ] off right now i'm
sorry i started off so strong and this
i gotta start rolling smaller joints man
now i gotta start rolling smaller joints
here we go
honda ready honda is making shoes for
the visually impaired
shoes you ready i read up on this
basically the shoes honda makes as for
peop
blind people people that can't see right
visually impaired just like a
the janitorial away from half baked or a
janitor if you want to be a dick about
it
a master of the custodial arts um for
the visually impaired sublime
[ __ ] all right
honda is making shoes so basically it
sets a jeep you can set where you're
going marty
and based on where you're at it'll tell
you and vibrate in your shoes which
direction you need to be going
did you hear that that's amazing oh yeah
you can't talk you're right next to me
go back to your microphone i'm sorry
i am so burnt camera switch i am
literally talking to you
talk your mind
honda ready visually impaired visually
impaired honda so that you put like a
gps into the shoe
has chips in the shoes and it vibrates
on which shoe and tells you where to go
be careful maybe you have to step off
somewhere and it tells you which
it's like tesla for shoes for for people
that are blind so yeah it's for more
independence they said
which is totally true could you imagine
that
not being able to see like the horrible
not even warm i'm not trying to down i'm
not trying to i'm saying no that's got
to be fun it's got to be terrible right
especially if you had to if you saw and
then went blind must be the worst
but for people that can not see yo you
must be just stuck
just what do you do hey can somebody
else help me
that's like sonar like like what bats
used yeah
yeah but imagine the liability that
thing doesn't go off you know
the person would walk into the [ __ ]
street
this is what's good marty you just
brought them
let's hope not man well when they were
explaining i was reading about tesla's
and they were explaining that like
i'm in this wearing the cameras and [ __ ]
so frames per second
each one of these cameras right now is
shooting 24
images per second those images blended
together make up video
okay that's a lot sounds creepy they
were explaining the tesla thinks i'm
gonna butcher this
in like a thousand frames per second so
it's seeing the road and
analyzing the conditions we can even see
it
like yeah like way faster than we could
ever process what's
happening so shout out to honda but it
sounds like tesla should have been doing
this is what you're saying
i don't know folks
[Laughter]
you said it like i caught you in a lie
man
this full head like some ulterior motive
to
i don't know folks i just got some
bitcoin and uh
did you get big one no [ __ ] no the only
other thing i know about tesla right now
yeah i mean
shout out to everybody making money but
i i just don't understand it we had
multiple people explaining to us
i'd rather just go buy some weed i know
it sounds stupid but i'd rather just go
buy some tangible weed
and smoke it and think of other
businesses and make money from those
i'm not that i'm so far from i'm in no
[ __ ] position to be going i'm just
buying [ __ ]
cryptocurrency and [ __ ] but
trying to buy a goddamn house so we'll
see
[ __ ] like an old man like
he's been trying to buy a house for a
[ __ ] year and a half well five we'll
see
this goddamn pandemics done us no favors
in this housing market
[ __ ] about this every episode but maybe
we'll get into some crypto after we
cross this [ __ ] bridge
too much fun for the soundboard sorry
too much fun uh the reason i was saying
that
tesla bring it up i said
oh that's what my brain said if there
was an armageddon and there was nothing
left and
cars had to be fixed i would be the only
human left on earth marty and i would
walk
i can't fix cars i'm not going to read a
manual if i read it i still wouldn't get
it i don't understand steps and formulas
in the quadratic form
it doesn't work for my brain my brain
doesn't work that way but i can make
all this other stuff easy right outside
my head think of an entire movie the
entire script
everything a joke but don't try to get
me to fix your car
everybody in my family's mechanics but
me
you should have seen us with the uh
remember we had a guest who caught a
flat out here
that alonso caught a flat and three
grown
four grown men three could not get get
the tire off why i mean i know how to
change the tire
he didn't have the tools we're trying
with the other tools like you know this
doesn't work yeah it felt like we
weren't knowing what the [ __ ] to do but
it was the jack's fault
yeah i was like yo i can't lift your car
up man
oh yeah that's what i was yeah got a
flat ass oh
no he said he caught a flat and still
came up because he noticed as he was
as he was driving over he's like
everybody i like you
i like that like i rolled in here sorry
sorry i'm late
sorry i'm late but my tire went flat i
said [ __ ] it
um yes shout out to honda what's good
sorry segment
sorry honda for [ __ ] on you talking
about [ __ ] tesla god damned is a good
car in a honda
it's not that good but it's okay see how
it's a honda i wouldn't expect
i mean it's can we just touch on how
[ __ ] random this is that honda would
make a
i think a shoe right i think it's great
but like
maybe nike
what's so random
yeah you're [ __ ] right you're
completely right
why is honda the driving company trying
to worry about people walking and not
buying cars yeah i was like
i get it i tax right off something i'm
researching i had the dude coming over
fixing my fridge and he's like yeah no
you want to buy a fridge from a company
that makes fridges you don't want to buy
a fridge from [ __ ]
lg they make tvs and [ __ ] they got into
fridges
you want to get the the general electric
[ __ ] all they do is make fridges
i wanted a sinus doctor not a [ __ ]
plastic surgeon
that got into sinuses at the end as you
[ __ ] somebody's nose up
uh-huh i feel you yeah you don't want
your yeah you're a scientist expert
specializing in boobs and butt lifts and
[ __ ] as i was walking as i was in the
waiting room i got to be honest
i went on their yelp and went the first
three things are a
horror story in the world oh my god my
face will never be the same
something my nose looks like i just
thought one no no no
[ __ ] and then i should have read like
yeah he stuck a needle in my eye
without me talking
it was awesome it was awesome it felt so
much better but damn he scared me
uh let's move on uh honda i'm very sorry
again for
us just [ __ ] all over you nike hey
jesus get it together what the [ __ ]
honda's coming and doing this [ __ ]
also bringing up one quick quick thing i
don't listen to kanye west anymore
because i listened to first two albums
then he
went weird and then got i thought he was
weird i was just
looking at memes i didn't look into it
the man is just
too smart i think i think he's just
imagine making a number one hit marty
and then doing it 400 times
and then writing songs okay what
i have imagined that okay oh yeah
exactly
so imagine him having to do that and
then going
i'm writing songs for people that are
winning awards and i'm
writing them i'm making them i'm gonna
just make my own music and then started
going number one
and then started killing everything and
then just making easy and doing all this
like
i saw what was like some most geniuses
are crazy
or have a little crazy in them you have
to be to be that smart i go
okay because they're all you know when
you think about musicians and like oh
smart are writers and they're just
weirdos but they're so good at what
they're like autism almost
yeah i mean or you could just have a
crazy ego too yeah he
obviously has an ego i get that but
don't you want that in your rapper
yeah for her i mean be crazy as [ __ ]
don't you want that your
favorite boxer yeah that's exciting you
want to hear what they're going to say
yeah you like damn i want to watch this
phone next time
that's crazy and connie wasn't the best
rapper in the [ __ ] world [ __ ] you
all right i gotta listen this new album
what the [ __ ] is forgot to say yeah and
if you back it up
like my grandma delores used to say like
mike uh we were watching boxing things
she said
i was a kid like [ __ ] six and
muhammad ali
old thing where he's doing the stutter
step and the butterfly [ __ ] and my
grandma's like he had the biggest mouth
so cocky but he
always backed it up that's the only
reason i like him that's why mcgregor
was the biggest sensation in the world
he was talking people
started yeah but it's all good i mean
after you can't always be on top man you
can't always be on top but um
i have no idea where i was going with
that mm-hmm i have no idea what we were
talking i can't decide if i'm excited
for this kind of mcgregor fight or not i
think i probably am
when is he fighting saturday i want to
see him fight [ __ ] nate diaz again
okay
we just saw this dustin poirier fight
god don't follow you he's gonna fight
him for let me bring up the speed he's
gonna fight him for a third time because
he just took a loss
like in the end of january the fight
just happened their normal
training camps are like as long as the
time that's passed he got
he got beat he's like we're gonna
[ __ ] run it back but he's he could
fight nate diaz for a third time too
nate d is nick diaz that's what
everybody wants to see but they fight
him
and they come on the show yeah that
they're we're from the same area man
they're my top picks for guests yeah
smoke weed man come smoke weed and talk
about beating people up that i know
probably i don't think nate's ever been
on a pack i mean i'm sure he has i
haven't seen him on a part he hasn't
been on rogue and i don't think or
anything
nick did his has though nick has i think
so mm-hmm bro
i i don't know i did see the thumbnail a
long time ago though mm-hmm well i mean
[ __ ] he's on the [ __ ] uh
intro music do you know what's him
training by day joe broken by nice yes
yeah that's awesome dude yeah that's
awesome because you always forget like
joe rogan like on top of having the
biggest show ever
yo you're the ufc guy like and have been
you have been for since
i was a kid i started watching you see
usc one you know you see two we should
random at blockbuster i mean my dad's
bet on the fights like the next one the
next one
uh the first couple ufc's paul john his
name is john and he's the polar bear
he's like seven foot tall white dude
that was my aunt's boyfriend
and that's why i was like wait that's my
ass ball oh man
like i was like more invested in it yeah
my head
dates that guy i never met him i'm like
that could be my uncle one day
you know what i mean so i was like five
like seven foot tall or six tanner's
damn bug sorry for everyone at home you
didn't know i was just [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] bug in my face anyway usc
all right
sean o'malley's fighting saturday too oh
really we're about to uh next time he's
in la yeah
yeah a little teaser we're gonna have uh
him come on down
smoke some [ __ ] we'd hang out
yeah yeah it's gonna be cool
yeah he could be the podcast uh fighter
you know what like a lot of podcasts a
lot of fighters come on podcast kind of
like recurringly
like dustin poirier goes on theo's
podcast a lot
gotcha guys so you know so my homies uh
sponsor what's his name the heavyweight
daniel cormier is that who you just
[ __ ] said
is that the name you just said and i
asked who was [ __ ] he is the heavyweight
i mean black dude yeah
kind of looks like rashad evans do you
remember
of course really remember when he was
kind of husky before he lost weight like
carl winslow
that's been out there people know that
like a young car because when he was fat
he was kind of he was kind of chunky
when he
entered the ultimate fighter or whatever
it was and i know he won it right and
that's how he started
probably it was fatter daniel cormier
yeah he's like uh
he's rogan's analyst partner now too
that guy but he's an active fighter i
really need to start watching ufc again
my homies
uh shout out to treat crew up in san
leandro i think
when he was fighting a fight it's a weed
company and he had their logo on his leg
because they're [ __ ] homie homies and
you see tree crew on his leg like yo
that's a [ __ ]
fighter with the wheel it was sick yeah
the ufc's were coming weed friendly now
yeah it seems uh he doesn't really like
rashad evan oh yeah see
at the bottom uh the bottom
go to the right more right right right
uh two more right there he loses every
shot evans
that's that's what i'm imagining with
the beard and scruff and [ __ ]
without without it he doesn't look like
him at all yeah he's one of my favorites
though dc is the [ __ ]
he almost he got into some heated
altercation with your boy
jake paul or some [ __ ] but like two you
have some i don't say your boy
i don't know don't be
don't do that to me i do that to other
people but
whenever i bring up someone that's gonna
suck hey your blood cousin your first
your firstborn
uh this guy that's my favorite thing to
do why would jake paul mess with him are
you [ __ ] kidding me
i don't [ __ ] know he's one of them
one of the paul brothers is boxing
[ __ ] tyrant it's him tyron woodley
this weekend one of the most shredded
ufc fighters we have
that's not gonna be good for him jake
paul's a youtube oh no he
they're fighting they're fighting
they're actually trying to be boxing so
i'm not going to knock anybody
you beat me up probably i don't know i'm
probably not but
still still i mean he's out there doing
this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did we be tyron
woodley is the [ __ ]
champ in the ufc yo these rants bro
these rants marty are unbelievable i
just backtracked and i remember how this
started
it's like branches off yeah yeah it's
like
it's it's like lightning when it hits
and it goes
that's our podcast guys that is the
podcast okay
i'm gonna let it join probably shouldn't
but here we go
how long how long are we at i'm gonna
say 118. 111 111 okay here we go
i'm sorry it's been a minute all right
meanwhile just talking [ __ ]
it feels like it's not even the podcast
like it feels like it does it feels like
we're on facetime doing nothing right
now
we have a bunch of guest episodes and
it's like we come back and it's like
something different chill yeah
all right cool cool yeah i know what
you're saying it's like the teacher's
not here
[Laughter]
doing anything's funny
or a sleepover as soon as the lights go
off and everybody's like
and everybody starts laughing and the
noise is [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's how i feel the dead person shut
the [ __ ] up i'm that dad now
oh man i remember oh wow
right before 9 11 this happened all
right my birthday september 6th
that weekend before 9 11.
we had a party and my mom was going to
the army
so she was studying up for her army [ __ ]
that night at my birthday party had like
five friends sleep over and never had
that happen
and we stayed up all night and made so
much noise in the dark
and remember uh who are we talking about
uh felipe esparza he's like you know you
you
all hit the poor queue and the lights go
off you start hitting each other
we did that with shoes that's why i said
oh i've done that before
this is the night the lights went off
and everybody was just like
it's making stupid noises and [ __ ] right
and then we're laughing and every
[ __ ] eight minutes my mom comes in
shut the [ __ ] up
i'm screaming because my mom was so
scary back then
but she liked all my homies so she'd
come and shut the [ __ ] up you're not
scaring the drill sergeants and [ __ ] at
the military bro that's how it was and
she looked at everybody
all right come on jesus and laugh about
it
[ __ ] jerks it was like are you
bipolar [ __ ] what's
what just happened she came into the
room burst in the room
maybe 15 times that night my friend my
mom
she got so heated at about two o'clock
in the morning but she was still
joking with us and i knew she was gonna
beat my [ __ ] ass cause everybody was
there
and it was almost like a point to like
[ __ ] with her
just for her to come in like we were all
so like
you want us to go to sleep we're all
like 11 12. uh-huh
it's like 11 years old 12 year olds like
in merced we're all 15 essentially one
of us
half these fools have banged girls come
on i was gonna say half these rules have
kids
yeah no for real one of them i'm
thinking right outside my head just
lives outside all right he was prepared
i have a dog i had a dog named janice
and my uh crazy stepdad oh
my wild ass stepdad name we will not
reveal almost said the [ __ ]
he had a dog too boxers outlaw outlaw in
janus named after janice joplin
um so i had like four years i was i knew
when i was like seven or eight or
something i can't remember
but my mom we were like yo why don't we
get water she just shut the [ __ ] up
nobody's leaving the room and she got
pissed at me and then she laughed and
everybody else was like what the [ __ ]
you [ __ ] laugh with me too
[ __ ] you these are my friends be nice to
me too
dude my friends had to go out my window
all right to use the hose because my mom
wouldn't let us out the wind to get
water
she was pissed no no one's getting
anywhere go to [ __ ] sleep
it's three i mean it's 3 15 coming
it's 3 20 sacks she would come in and
say like update us on the [ __ ] times
dude we had no phones
all right i had tamagotchi maybe that
was dead because i overfed the [ __ ]
that's it and then my homie
jumps out the window two of them and
they forgot i had dogs but i'm like they
don't bite
just chill they jumped out the window
came back in because the dogs were
barking and they got scared and my homie
jumped in and broke my bed right in
[ __ ] half
he jumped in my bed frame just snapped i
don't think oh my [ __ ] god if it's
getting
if it wasn't bad my mom's gonna [ __ ]
uppercut me dude
you guys don't know what you're doing
like it's all fun yeah it's fun it's
funny it's great huh
you guys are leaving my mom says the
second the [ __ ] sun's up
everyone's leaving at six in the morning
everyone [ __ ] left
nobody went to sleep she goes the second
the sun's up you're all leaving
and they did my mom made i remember
everyone leaving
as as the sun came up
nobody's mom dropped them off everybody
walked there or something [ __ ] ghetto
kids
so the reason i said that is because
in the middle of the night we just all
took our shoes and started throwing them
in this
in the pitch black i mean gunning shoes
and my friend scott ducey he got popped
right here he's a bit the little guy
like the littlest dude
he got hit in the nose she was busted
bleeding everywhere
and nobody stopped we turned the light
on scott's like no
and they turned it back on to make sure
he was okay over there and it just kept
going
and it [ __ ] hurt but i remember right
before like all right where's everybody
blade mode
i'm throwing shoes and [ __ ] um and then
the bed broke anyway a couple days later
is when 9 11 happened and my mom was
going to take her test
the day the morning it happened and i
was oh i feel sick
and i stayed home on 9 11. all right i
stayed home it was a tuesday i remember
i think
i'm pretty positive it was [ __ ]
tuesday
and then i saw the [ __ ] going on the
news i was watching cartoons all the new
[ __ ] was happening
and i'm like what my mom's going to
sacramento the capital to take the test
like if they're going to bomb california
the [ __ ] capital
where all the buildings are right i mean
obviously i was dumb kid it was probably
la
or frisco but yes and i was tripping my
mom's phone was off she was taking the
test and all she never took the test
because all that crazy [ __ ] happened she
got there and that's when all the
[ __ ] buildings were coming down
but i i remember dude just like freaking
the [ __ ] out not being able to get a
hold of her and it was such a trip
like this is happening of course my
mom's gonna go there right now [ __ ]
you know what i mean it was like such a
like holy [ __ ] the timing did she go to
the military
no she stopped because we win the
[ __ ] war okay i was gonna say that
she's like no your dad's not gonna take
care of you [ __ ] that i was only gonna
go in the military
and everyone help me out this next get
some [ __ ] benefits because my mom's
always worked hella hard so she was
trying to think of like how do i make
more money i'm gonna [ __ ] army [ __ ]
it
and then as soon as i have she came home
i was like i'm done as fab i think is
what's called the
the test as fab or some [ __ ] and i
remember she was studying for weeks on
that [ __ ] my step oh my god almost
his name again i showed you the picture
my stepdad right i found on the internet
guys holy [ __ ] he does not look like the
same stepdad anymore
you saw that evil face oh he's sitting
indian style on a
[ __ ] like he looked scary yeah
like he had no life in his eyes
i googled him i'm like you know what
does he look like now and i found an
arrest picture
and he's in there's a prison picture and
he's
i just had to show you who i'm talking
about is that what you imagined
yeah okay like just kind of he was like
but he's a lot skinnier now though right
oh yeah yeah that picture he's drug drug
addict
he's not like when my mom's just first
got and he's just
edward norton american history x like he
was rocked rocked out
and it was so weird he was so skinny and
he's sitting curling like 110s and i go
is that a lot because i didn't know but
that's a lot man yeah that's a lot of
weight little prison bars with the the
bar that does this
remember the curl bar with the grooves
and he's just
ah he's hitting i'm like oh my god
just curling water jugs and [ __ ] no he
didn't go like that
but he was doing pull-ups on the bars
and he's holding on to the uh punching
bag with one arm i was like holding his
body up
like some gymnast and he's like you're
gonna work out with me hold
on he started telling me about some type
of dinosaurs he was super smart he
started explaining dinos and then he's
like
in spanish blah blah blah blah and he's
trying to teach me some spanish we're
outside
i don't remember anything else after
that day all right after that time of
that that day but
you tried teaching about dinosaurs
spanish and lifting weights in all the
same day it was crazy
but anyway that picture of him why why
did we get on this topic
[ __ ] god my brain yes that picture how
scary is that man
don't want to be in a room with that guy
yeah no you don't want to like wake up
and have them like
hovering over your bed like that's how i
would that's the vibes you gave to me
you saw that like that demeanor was just
like yeah
oh bro you murk fools huh oh
he didn't look like the same i mean same
tattoos obviously because he was covered
head to toe there's no more room
he had the same tattoos as when my mom
broke up with him
15 20 years ago probably been a pretty
rough life since then i'd imagine
i told you you saw him that one time he
was twacked out he was showing all these
two weeks to fix the car
that's the last time i ever saw him like
oh no i dodged him i saw him at the i
talked about this on the podcast where i
started going to college and he was
going to college too
to get different degrees because he had
like 18 degrees but couldn't get no job
he had
so many felonies i'd say i saw him or no
i think i don't know if he said it on
the podcast where he just told me
oh but i saw him at my college and i
ducked him
i never once said hi to him because he
was gone
he had shaved bald head see all his
tattoos
mustache and just books hell of books
though
and he's such a smart person but he's so
twacked and like
years of prisons like don't talk to him
don't
don't and i saw him with i feels like my
first semester is called no no no no no
it's not like i just i i wanted to walk
up to him and i saw him twack went nope
i don't want this type of attachment
because he's still trying to bug my mom
like eight years later like he's loving
my mom's stuff
and uh i just didn't want it
that's the last time i saw him until i
saw that picture and went oh my god
this man's gone he's no he just needs to
go to jail
i guess where he lives that's where he's
most comfortable yeah but seeing that
picture was scary man when i found that
picture i could not believe
it like that i found that quick
well there's your uh that was your male
role model yeah
[Laughter]
white supremacist what a trip
what an upbringing i never think about
it i never think about it i just think
about my stepdad and it was like oh he's
a white dude
oh he's scary growing up
here we go let's go let's get on to the
next topic all right guys um yeah we're
ranting we're ranting and oh sorry guys
i know you guys like it but i've had
where are we at 120
two 122. i said let's keep an hour and a
half today marty
i haven't even got to my stories it's
all right
catching up oh god yeah all right yes
we're catching up
what's up guys welcome to our mid role
ad read and this is brought to you by
betterhelp when marty and i were
approached by this company it's
automatically something i said yes to
marty and i both said yes to because
this is something i
we both really really feel that can help
people this is something
i feel i wish was invented before better
help is online counseling
all right guys this is literally a
therapist you could talk to online
through your phone it's an app and a
website so you know how many people out
there
that probably aren't here anymore just
because they didn't have anybody to talk
to
they had no outreach ahead or maybe they
were embarrassed to go to a therapist
maybe they're embarrassed to be seen in
the office or
going to the principal's office or the
counselor asking for help
do you see what i'm saying some people
have too much pride maybe some people
are scared
maybe they don't know where to turn this
is a new era guys this is technology
driven
this is something i can see anyone
benefiting from
even me i've been through it man i've
been overwhelmed to the point i just lay
there i've been in the
days where i didn't know what it was
this is years ago i
i just didn't know what was going on i
was just so overwhelmed just
stuck if this is something you think you
can benefit from if it's something that
interests you right now go to
betterhelp.com forward slash dope
that's 10 off your first month guys this
is completely confidential all right
this is some this is a actual licensed
therapist coming to talk to you it's 24
7. you can send a message at any time
this is not a self-help line this is not
a crisis line this is professional
counseling guys you talk to somebody
this is the person that matches with you
someone that's compatible with you you
guys talk it out
this is how this works and if you don't
want to go to a therapist you don't want
to go to the office at all
this is how you do it this is the new
wave guys this is technology right now
individual counseling team counseling
couples counseling this is for
anyone and everyone maybe right now
you're sitting with a friend that
in their head like you know i'm checking
this out because maybe they're shy maybe
they're embarrassed maybe they don't
know
how to reach out for help or how to some
people just need someone to talk to
sometimes man
that's truly what it is and if you don't
have that now you have it you have a
phone can you watch this then you can
talk to somebody
so like i said before betterhelp.com
forward slash dope
i have a story for you guys and i don't
think i talked about it man i could
did i talk about this i really hope i
didn't
okay for everyone at home if i really
all right damn it marty
if he sounds familiar stop me all right
i don't like to fight you guys know that
when i was in the sixth grade i started
wrestling
and there was this eighth grader and he
was a dick and we're the same weight
class
i didn't talk about this i don't think
so okay here we go
we're the same way class name is brandon
[ __ ] you his name's brandon eat it dick
and uh he was a dick to me and i'm super
nice and people [ __ ] with me and i just
i talk [ __ ] i make fun of heavy right
like we talked about
he's way older than me and i beat him
for the starting spot sixth grader i
i don't know i [ __ ] him up
and the worst thing about tanaya tryouts
are in the cafeteria which is normal
that's where the mats are you know after
school the matches right marty you know
wrestling matches you know when they did
our tryouts
at [ __ ] lunch time when everyone was
in the cafeteria eating
watching us i i
i auditioned for wrestling and sweats
i was pissed i'm thinking you know i
better [ __ ] win man
every one of my homies right now is in
the [ __ ] room looking
we didn't need to see the list of the
who made it everyone knows who [ __ ]
made it all right because they're
watching us while eating
all our free lunch with berg the two
little mini sliders in the plastic bag
and the milks that you pop in their bag
anyway i go up and i see the first kick
of his neck [ __ ] rung
swung fireman's carried basically boom
i went damn he's gonna cry
[ __ ] he cried like dude i really hope
who's my guy and then i finally see who
i'm going against like yo he's an
8th grader [ __ ] [ __ ]
i remember i'm a year behind so if i'm
in sixth grade i'm
10 going on 11 right
and uh i this gets 13 going to 14.
and he's bigger than me and i'm thinking
that doesn't matter but i'm scared
and my dad's a wrestler he's taught my
whole life what to do anyway i go up
and i just i just do whatever i can do i
just dip him super hard and i hear his
air come out i dip in my opinion in like
15 seconds
and i remember as i get up kermit the
frog [ __ ]
[ __ ] pain full [ __ ] vibes come in
like all right i'm gonna step off
remembering that when he's like when uh
when ace is grilling the kermit the frog
fool and the club like you gotta [ __ ]
chill uh-huh he goes you
get with the programmer you leave and he
leaves i'ma step off
when he knew like don't kill him now
that's bad when i dipped that kid
brandon and choked the life out of him
as i got up he gave me that look i'm a
step oh my god oh i'm gonna have a
[ __ ] problem
this kid's gonna be a [ __ ] second
people were laughing
mm-hmm it was over and i was like no i
[ __ ] up this motherfucker's gotta do
that that's got a vendetta on me
hard that's the kind of look like
oh no as i get up like oh i made it i
guess
[ __ ] you're i'm on varsity over you
oh god okay here we go
anyway this doesn't sound familiar no
thank god
all right [ __ ] you brandon so uh the kid
starts picking on me
i beat him and he's picking on me
knowing i can [ __ ] him up
but i don't hit p like i'm i'm a timid
kid i guess you would say
i'm a loudmouth [ __ ] though i am
talking [ __ ] to this kid brandon talk
i mean making fun of his mom
just anything i can do and he's the kid
that just does his chest thing and goes
you want to fight
you want to fight you know those kids
that's to do the chats for 30 minutes
huh
what's up then he's that kid i'm like yo
get out get away from me man get away
from me
the other thing is if i hate you my
mom's gonna beat the [ __ ] out of me for
getting in trouble
i can't get in trouble so for like three
weeks this kid's [ __ ] with me like
trying to do the flinch thing when i
walk by him in the
hallway and i and i always make fun of
him and i never flinched
so he would get really mad then i come
to find out he's a [ __ ] wiener
and everybody in eighth grade doesn't
like him because he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
to people
he's like oh doyle but oh doyle got his
ass whooped all the time
so he got knocked the [ __ ] out by like
three gangbangers already for talking
[ __ ]
he's like the one white kid with
freckles in our whole [ __ ] school and
you're gonna be talking [ __ ] to the
asian gangbanger kid shut up
right and uh
anyway he's [ __ ] with me for weeks
dude like trying to [ __ ] with me in
front of people
and i'm in wrestling practice just
grilling his head into the [ __ ]
ground and after when we're in class
he's being mean to me but i'm not gonna
grill his head we're not
a wrestling practice you know i'm a kid
man i'm a kid i don't want to get in
trouble i don't want to be
in detention i don't want to get kicked
out
[ __ ] though i wish i would have felt now
and i would have knocked i would have
american history curbed his ass like
it's different now like don't [ __ ] with
me what's wrong with you
but i was a kid anyway this doesn't
sound familiar oh my god all right
anyway
i go home i finally tell my mom like mom
this kid it will not stop
i explained to her she goes thomas beat
the [ __ ] out of him i don't
care are you starting it i go no all
right
if he touches you smack the [ __ ] out of
him i go
cool and i remember thinking
how can i get him to hit me how can i
get him to start to swing so i can
beat the [ __ ] out of him cause
damn once again this don't sound
familiar god
i tell so much story time some similar
stories i saw so many story times that i
was like
to tell on the story time does it sound
my podcast or is it in my brain i'm
reliving it
uh-huh i think we're good okay
there's this girl named sarah and she's
about six
two six three she's a tall girl she's a
husky chick
but she's super slow like she's mentally
handicapped
i know that because i've worked with the
handicapped kids in seventh grade i've
been in pals
seventh through twelfth grade like i i
love that class all you do is chill with
these kids that are super [ __ ] nice
like it's the most fun class like yo
what do you want to do today don't play
blitz again
let's play blitz again like all right
cool what do you want to do you want to
make
arts and crafts what's [ __ ] do we
even play dodgeball like it's it's
[ __ ] cool
i know she's slow by the way she talks
and what class she's
in and the new balance is with velcros
like she's a slow she's slow i know her
she has a different brother like oh
she's slow
she's so nice and she had a crush on me
and i was a sixth grader she was an
eighth grader same great as him and she
like
in the hallway like i thomas all the
time because i was in her class
yeah i knew she had a crush on me right
but i'm like
first off i'm a child i don't want to
i'm a kid
and then i'm [ __ ] also five [ __ ]
four foot three
like i'm i'm good
right so i'm not gonna date some girl
anyway
i knew that and she always say hi to me
in the hallway and brandon was really
mean to her
like oddly like mean to the handicapped
girl
and people knew that and i think that's
why you always got [ __ ] with because
he was a dick
anyway ah the night my mom tells me
smack the [ __ ] out of my
oh hell yeah and then i was i remember
was getting a [ __ ]
fruitopia remember from topia drinks i
was getting out of our new machines at
the ghetto school we had machines now
frootopia i remember one time they had
pepsi blue once
and uh i was gonna get i was about to
get a drink if you're from tanaya
if you go to tonight if i'm looking at
the cafeteria to the right it's a
basketball court
behind me is the trees in the benches to
the left is wood shop straight from his
cafeteria
the one to the left all right that soda
machine
as i'm about to press it i look over i
see sarah i said oh i'm sarah's name
damn i see sarah
and she's like this right and remember
she's tall as [ __ ]
she's looking down like when people hit
their dog and their dog's all weird
she's like that and this full brandon is
doing this [ __ ] to her the flint's
[ __ ] to her
and then he goes like that and he pushes
her against the checkered wall by the
music room and i went no way
holy [ __ ] this is really happening [ __ ]
yeah
i'm gonna [ __ ] this kid up like i'm
definitely not getting in trouble
this is [ __ ] i mean like first off i
know her and she's very [ __ ] cool and
nice and she's slow [ __ ]
you know that you [ __ ] she couldn't have
been doing nothing wrong
where he checked her in the passing
right no clearly he was a piece of [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] i didn't go up and beat
the [ __ ] out of him because still
my mom says he has to touch you first
don't be [ __ ] beating somebody up i
remember she said i'm like
how do i get him to swing on me this
doesn't sound familiar right no
okay cool sorry
so i remember i walked up i do the whole
kid thing where i'm oh man i walk up
hella fast and right when i get there i
slow down like
so i was like nervous heart just going
crazy because i'm like
i've never been in like a fight in
school before [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] except for
that one piece of [ __ ] guys smacked in
the face for calling me
a piece [ __ ] it's different i walked up
and sarah's looking at me
and i'm like what's wrong with you phil
what are you doing what are you doing
uh he was like shut the [ __ ] up the [ __ ]
of me does that chest thing to me and i
did it back to him and he got
all butt hurt that i'm like [ __ ] you
and i heard sarah's looking at me and
i'm thinking
bro she can [ __ ] you up if she
wanted to but she's [ __ ] slow
she was like something about mary uh
brother
like capable talking going to school but
you can tell something's
off like i almost want to cry right now
thinking about that [ __ ] like
that's why would i remember i was so
[ __ ] mad
i was so [ __ ] mad and this fool
starts doing the chest thing
and then i make fun of him in front of
like three of my friends
and this full i don't know what came
over him
but like he did the flinch thing again
and
went like that and stopped right here
and i went
oh [ __ ] i thought you could touch me so
i can beat your ass and he stopped
and i [ __ ] did the flinch thing on
him and he
curled up and everyone went oh
you know that's cool [ __ ] because there
was at that time there's we're doing
chest thing for 30 minutes yeah yeah
there's [ __ ] 20 kids around now
and the asian gangster kid that got
murdered i remember the asian gateway
got killed he was in eighth grade too he
was the he was that all bald head one
strip of hair
all the way back asian gangster all the
blue all the time but he was mad tall i
remember like yeah that's a tall ass
made me think of rufio how you said that
[ __ ]
yeah but not not extravagant like that
just like a strip of that gang banger
[ __ ] uh mod [ __ ]
hair [ __ ] and i remember he's standing
there
and i'm looking around like oh [ __ ] dude
i hope i can [ __ ] beat this kid up
like
yeah i'm a kid and as everybody goes
he gets so upset he just [ __ ] swings
and pushes me like
like a swing push i don't know how to
explain like he wanted to punch me but
he was scared so he went
like a push of i don't know i don't know
what to call it
but he hit me in the chest and i had my
backpack on so i went to take my
backpack off and as i did he just
tried to bear hug me and this is why i
always talk about this
i am a [ __ ] baller all right because
i did this [ __ ] in real life
explain for everyone at home in the car
or whatever you can't see
dope's usual podcast on youtube you're
going to need to see this all right here
we go
can't explain this so he's right here
and i'm taking my backpack off so my
hands are like about to come out
underneath my strap so i can take it off
right i'm stuck
because he bear hugs my arm so i'm like
oh what did i do
marty [ __ ] stone cold started 316.
all right this kid's standing right here
right so he's like right here and i got
my [ __ ] and he's bear hugging me
so i'm like oh i just go and i grab his
hand and i just dropped to my ass bam
stone cold stunner did him in real
[ __ ] life
i thought like i had bought him i was
too cool like i didn't know what to do
so i'm like
just go to the ground go to the ground
cause we're wrestlers i'm like go take
him his ass to the ground
i bet when i have him he's standing so
when i drop my weight out of nowhere bam
on my ass he's standing goes yeah and i
hear him go
up like a little squeal because i
[ __ ] like i had his
neck and so i take my [ __ ] backpack
off we're on the ground
and i just start [ __ ] christmas story
punching the [ __ ] out of his hips
and like his stomach and i start hitting
him in the chest i feel like i've told
this story damn it i know i talk about
story time but
i'm [ __ ] smacking the [ __ ] out of him
i'm looking up
and the asian gangster kids like that
like [ __ ]
willy wonka tattoo uh-huh yeah he's like
that yeah
yeah yeah and uh i'm [ __ ]
hitting him hitting him and i look at
him and he starts crying and i'm like oh
bro i gotta stop because i
you know i mean like he now wants me to
stop first he was trying to fight me now
he's like oh my god stop please
so he's crying i'm like oh bro now i
feel like a [ __ ] bully
like [ __ ] man i start getting up right
get up he [ __ ] kicks me
like kicks up at me and i go oh hell no
and i jump on him and start
beating the [ __ ] out of him again a
piece of [ __ ] what a piece of [ __ ] i'm
hitting him
right right here like on the back of the
rib
as hard as i can like as hard as i
[ __ ] can
i can feel it like how much it hurts i
i know i was hurting this kid like i was
hitting him very very [ __ ] hard but i
didn't want him in the face i was scared
remember i think we talked about have we
talked about the first time you're
hitting on me in the face
yeah yeah i was 20 [ __ ] five okay
so i'm in the sixth grade at this time i
never hit nobody in the face i still
hadn't
but damn this joint when i was how
intense this is all right
so as i'm beating the [ __ ] out of this
kid i
am like i'm not gonna stop until someone
stops me
and everyone's cheering in his grade
like
they know him they're like yes little
sixth grader and that that
crazy girl shireen's little brother you
know oh [ __ ] he's [ __ ] this kid
up and he's in the wrestling team
everybody knows like
that's a problem some kid that knows how
to wrestle and you just start [ __ ]
bullying and he
i picked you down to the ground i took
your spot [ __ ]
yes why would you think this is okay
exactly
i didn't expect a stone cold stone but
it's out of necessity my arm was stuck
and i went
oh [ __ ] that dropped and i remember our
heads were together and he was all
sweaty and [ __ ]
i remember everything about i wish sarah
would have [ __ ] sparta kicked him in
the chest out of you
it was really sad she was like whenever
you hit a dog type [ __ ] she was like in
the corner like
it was [ __ ] bad i remember it was it
was terrible
but i remember it's like [ __ ] yeah i'm
hitting the [ __ ] i'm thinking my mom's
i'm fine i'm good beating the [ __ ] it
was a friday i'm thinking if i get
suspended
start monday [ __ ] straight two
days off right now i'm like [ __ ] it
and i'm hitting him and i feel somebody
grab me and i'm like [ __ ] you
i don't hear nobody like get off the
principal get off of the
i don't hear a teacher i feel someone
grab me so i get pissed
like what kid is getting me the [ __ ] off
right now man we're in the [ __ ]
ghetto man
he's the minority there's four white
kids yeah right
he's one of them sarah was one too
randomly
and um so all these mexican kid asian
kids gang bangers are [ __ ] like
cheering and [ __ ]
i remember the asian kid specifically
cheering and i feel the hand grabbing me
and i'm like get the
[ __ ] and as i go get the [ __ ] i'd lift
off the ground
i'm wrestling at 140 135 in sixth grade
i was a fat kid i was 135.
can you palm 135 up in the air
no maybe if it's a kid yeah maybe if
it's a kid
but not a weight you can't 135 if it's a
child in your life what the [ __ ]
you crying i was just picturing me
lifting april up
[Laughter]
i come off the ground i see my feet
leave the ground and go whoever this is
i ain't [ __ ] with
you i mean like this person picked me up
holy [ __ ] whoever this kid is i ain't
swinging on him was it your sister
we're right by the cafeteria i go like
there's like five feet
seven feet and there's a wall on the
other side of the soda fountain
i get dropped i turn around and it's mr
herforth
which is you ever seen a bug's life he's
a stick insect
but a human he's 6'4 120
he is a stick figure yeah
and i see that it's him and he goes [ __ ]
out and he's super nerd
nice stick insect he's kelsey grammer
frasier yeah
and [ __ ] out i go oh i'm not moving
because this
my my idea was the second you let me
down kid wherever you are
i ain't gonna fight you but i'ma run it
back and bruce lee stop this
[ __ ]
he kicked me i was pissed you know
i was like yo mr herford i'm done
skinniest man on the planet
one-armed me nope i'm out i know how
much i weigh
i can't lift that and i sat there and
then
30 seconds later here he comes with
brandon and brandon's just [ __ ]
crying holding his stomach in his sides
and he's
going in with the crying like i can see
by pissing blood
i'm hitting him hard in the ribs and the
kidneys or whatever like
it's pretty bad [ __ ] him up
and he sets us by each other and the
whole time mr herfe is like
i'm calling the principal oh well he
gets on his walkie-talkie he's talking
he's calling the security of the school
and the whole time here's brandon i'm
looking at him like this
i'm gonna [ __ ] murder you like i'm
just like [ __ ] you mister herself
he looks back i'm just like oh
fight he turns back to get this cured
i'm like i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] i was so mad he
was to my left
but yeah anyway i was looking at him
like i'm gonna [ __ ]
didn't even get my frutopia first off a
pissed
uh go to the principal's office best
part about the story go to the
principal's office principles pit no
vice principal mr kaikendoll looks just
like dave grohl the lead singer the foo
fighters
it looks just like his ass he was very
cool
i had got suspended i got in-house
suspension
for three days earlier that year
because i was stone cold stunning kids
me and chad holland
we were he would distract him i'd come
up to the kids
it was like you know you do open chest i
was stone cold stuttering kids
and he loved me because right when he
asked me in the principal's office i go
yeah i have just i've never had a kid
tell me the truth
i'm not going to suspend you in-house
suspension
and he goes why are you doing that i
just like wrestling man
he's like so chad i'm like me and chad
love wrestling
me and him met because he had a stone
cold stunner a stone cold shirt on i go
you like
wrestling like i said earlier you just
meet kids that's how i met chad in sixth
grade go
triple it i triple h
like like we were friends and we started
stone cold stuttering
our friends but one kid we stone cold
started apparently his sister saw and
thought we were bullying him so she told
us i found out that in senior year who
it was
don't say your last name but [ __ ]
david come on man
i'm sorry i was really going full four
stone cold starting no all the way to
the ground but so when i stole costume
in the fight
i was so proud it was like unintentional
completely
getting to the office sorry getting to
the office and dave grohl's like
hey why did you guys do this why are you
fighting and i just went
i turned at brandon and i go why are we
fighting brandon
hey bro right when i go he was
punking sarah and i said her last name
and the teacher goes
or mr kaikendoll the vice principal just
looks at
me like lost
looks at brandon goes you did what to
sarah and he said her last name
you did what and i go
do you understand why i did that he goes
thomas we don't have to talk about
anything else just just sit here
called his dad call my mom his dad got
that his dad looks scary
his dad grabbed the back of his neck so
[ __ ] tight
i was like yo maybe you get your ass
whooped down that's what i was thinking
i was assuming that
all right that way you're so mean but
don't take it on sarah you
[ __ ] and me i'm what the [ __ ] anyway
oh doyle rules type of kid his dad
what did you do he grabbed his neck he
you could tell his dad was like
you did have to explain to her to the
dad that she was a special guest
what did you do as a dad at that point
like i don't know i
you take the kid out to the desert and
just
that's why it is scary like do you
should you kill your kid
like i've reached such a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's sad that's a bad feeling
anyway uh grinch smile
i looked told him just waited there for
20 minutes
i just look like side eye and just
waiting for him to look at me so i'm
gonna [ __ ]
kill you but you're crying i'll [ __ ]
kill your ass like i was just i was so
mad still
oh as we were waiting there for the
security to come the asian kid came up
and [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the kid that
died a little bit later but
he came out she's like oh [ __ ] go [ __ ]
he was like like tapping me on the
shoulders and like looking at brandon
like
[ __ ] you and they were thinking like
oh so i'm not i'm not the bad guy here
good [ __ ] yeah
because like i felt bad he was crying
and i was going in on his ass
and anyway um
long story short my sister got in
trouble that same day because of her
grades
we were going camping with my dad the
next day i got suspended for a week
still got to go camping
that's why another reason why my sister
[ __ ] hated me for a year
because i went camping my dad we never
saw my dad my sister had to stay home
she had like [ __ ] one point
something i was a 4.0 student but
i got to go and i [ __ ] got in trouble
am i just like he's suspended how the
[ __ ] is he going camping
you were a goddamn hero though and all
actually she still hated the fast
forward she was even
more they still they suspended you
though this week i had to
they had to they said or four days four
or five days that's a whole week for
school
anyway i remember crying and i was like
we're good man
like i understand thank you like he was
like
i get it but i remember the way he
looked at brandon was like
yeah you did what but i remember sitting
there like oh
this is the first time i'm happy to be
the principal i can't wait yeah let's
talk about it
let's talk about it today what the [ __ ]
happened i told my mom my mom got there
and she looked at the kid like oh this
little piece of [ __ ] you were telling me
about oh my mom was
heated and then when she found out what
i did she was like
[ __ ] yeah she was all hyped up mm-hmm
she was so hyped i got suspended anyway
what camping with my dad the next day
i'm actually gonna do a story time about
that because some crazy [ __ ] happened to
us when we were camping
so it's just wild she had to call the
[ __ ] cops type [ __ ]
we were camping in now like shasta mount
shasta
something i can't remember um anyway
that's a story of me
beating up this kid and how did brandon
turn out in life
he never looked to talk to me again we
were wrestling partners
still never said a word to me in
practice i just dipped him
extra [ __ ] hard like extra hard just
anytime i could i was [ __ ] his [ __ ]
up
trying to dislocate his shoulder type
[ __ ] when i dipped him like
full force full [ __ ] force in
practice as much as i possibly could
um he was an eighth grader i don't know
yeah later on that year his
jaw got snapped in [ __ ] half hanging
he was trying to talk [ __ ] some gangster
king the kid [ __ ] his [ __ ] up
and i remember seeing like his [ __ ] was
wired hmm
wait was it wired i think it was wired
but the [ __ ] was broke
yeah brandon [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
i won't say your last name but you know
you are that was some [ __ ] [ __ ] you
anyway i always think about me talking
about these people they're gonna get
like [ __ ] crazy and show up here i'm
like
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up again do you not
realize that like i'm gonna beat the
show you again
but um that's the story of me fighting
this kid named brandon
don't be don't be a piece of [ __ ] and we
won't talk about you yeah
i don't know why i brought it up i just
decided to talk about the story today
there's a fight story
no that [ __ ] is enraging it was crazy
bro it was crazy and you know
what two years later my did we talk
about this
i don't know what you're doing um
because i had a little [ __ ] did i tell
you about this we had my my little
sister died when i was a kid or no
no she didn't die look at my mom had to
like
she came out [ __ ] up i guess she had a
missing chromosome or some [ __ ]
so like they had i don't know what
happened i just know she didn't live
right i can't remember like i don't know
if they had to abort the bait i don't
know what it was
but something happened where they're
like yo she's a vegetative state or some
[ __ ]
but i remember like a year later that
happened i'm like yo i might have a
sister i gotta take care of like i'm
with it i don't give a [ __ ] that's cool
like
yeah i mean as a kid cause i'm in all
these classes like i know how to [ __ ]
help type [ __ ] you know
but uh ugh but i remember that and i
remember thinking like
you [ __ ] up brandon because if that
was my sister and you did some [ __ ] i'd
come
kill you mm-hmm i'd murder i'd [ __ ]
stab you in school
kill you as fast as i could just stab
you in the neck
i mean can you blame him yeah well
that's not even my sister some girl i
know
but as i'm saying like you know that was
my sister because i almost had a sister
like sarah you know
and uh it was just a trip man
like such a weird it was just weird
that guy's a piece of [ __ ] yeah he was
he you got to be an extra piece of [ __ ]
to take down to not only just be
bullying you and random kids but then
like that yeah i'm sure
like some butterfly effect was going on
bullying
and getting asked his ass that's the
other weird thing that's like where
you're not you're not even good at this
you're not just getting it from you've
never punked anybody successfully except
for sarah
never once says he punked somebody like
under the ground no it doesn't happen
he was being mean to me but i want to
beat his ass i don't want what
happened happened i knew what was gonna
happen like
well do you understand you know even
though i'm younger
but anyway that's the story and uh
randomly brought that story i don't even
know why i brought it up
because we're talking about ufc that's
just a good story i don't know
anyway that's in the fight story time on
uh dobajiola channel
why'd you bring up worldstar because i
saw somebody ddt a [ __ ] on there
the other day and i can't
yeah he like that's deadly some dude was
uh chasing him down the street or
whatever and he just like
the dude caught up to him and he caught
put him in a headlock
boom dropped him right on the street
he's like stop [ __ ] with me
and the dude just staggered off like why
are these people
starting [ __ ] with people and getting
[ __ ] yeah
show this but i saw some [ __ ] on michael
rappaport's page speaking of michael
rappaport
he post some crazy [ __ ] today well he
posts like
he pulls [ __ ] to piss people off like
yeah well he posted this guy like
shooting roman candles at this girl
yeah i saw that yeah
yeah it seemed like a lot she definitely
got burned blistered
yeah that's what i thought of when we
first started talking about the goalie
i don't know where he stopped that it
was so odd to see
it made me like pissed off yeah stopped
it he was chasing her around for like
minutes
literally over a minute you can see her
hair smoking at one point yeah
it was weird i hope he knows her it said
baby mama on the
oh maybe she's a jerk that still doesn't
that doesn't justify that but yeah i
don't know man [ __ ] are crazy
i don't know maybe like i mean [ __ ] you
see like in chicago [ __ ] hundred
people get killed over the weekend
is that real numbers is that real
that's a war zone yeah that's like
[ __ ] it's so
normal another country
yeah every time you see chicago well
it's a big number and it happens again
like that's a bigger number
wow because it's become so normal like
[ __ ] man that's ridiculous
so sad so many like if you were to fill
up 100 people in this warehouse it's
like
so many people to die in a weekend yeah
you know what i always think of when
people get shot and killed and all that
and people
don't remember like boom
funeral [ __ ] play food
a ripple across everybody oh my gosh
[ __ ] everybody take a day off
to go to the [ __ ] funeral and then
have to reminisce for three weeks about
this person like
yo you caught so much [ __ ] and then
the revenge from that like you saw the
story about the
little kid getting shot in the
drive-through like a couple like two
weeks ago or whatever
what man this is all world star [ __ ] i'm
speaking about what do you mean
what the [ __ ] is it talking about first
of all while he's in the drive-through
yeah there was some [ __ ] where like some
dude was in a music video and he was
like
you know doing real disrespectful [ __ ]
so like some people's graves and [ __ ]
and then happened
his [ __ ] car got shot and his kid was
in it while they're in the [ __ ]
mcdonald's
oh yeah
damn that's sad again i don't know what
the [ __ ] i'm talking about but that is
the type of [ __ ] that does obviously
happen
yeah crazy [ __ ] happens all the time bro
crazy [ __ ] happens
that's sad that sad as [ __ ] yeah damn
dude what the [ __ ] happened
that story got me all off topic i mean
got me all out of whack and [ __ ] i feel
like
i don't even know what we talked about
today i got to be honest i got to start
smoking some
oh that's what i was going to bring up
i'm going to switch up my weeds i'll
start smoking like a little
diva mixed in with little drinks i never
thought i'd hear you say that i'm going
to try it through
you're usually so disgusted by sativas
certain ones but
i smoke all ge and like heavy strains
all day every day
all day and like maybe i should switch
it up
i always complain like yo i'm [ __ ]
exhausted but i can't sleep
like because i'm insomniac but maybe i
shouldn't just be tired
that could have definitely some i'm sure
if you went to a doctor they'd be like
that might have something to do with it
tired all day
and at night when i'm not tired it sucks
being tired is the [ __ ]
for a [ __ ] 28 years basically he says
i can't remember
i haven't been able to sleep since the
first [ __ ] great here we go
here we go where are we at two hours
almost
sorry guys that joint is strong
here we go i have i haven't drank water
yet in two [ __ ] hours
sorry here we go
bless you sorry for everyone at home
this is uh long gaps in time i'm just
high
[Music]
it's like [ __ ] i hate down time so i
feel like three seconds of no talking it
drives me [ __ ] insane i ha
you can't be in the car waiting like
wait did it skip did i get a text
did i get a dead zone did a phone die
like i hate that [ __ ]
so i really hate long pauses and
podcasts they're the [ __ ] worst
actually
so i try not to do that here we go
guys i have one more story for you all
right i know i know it's been a long
time it's two hours i got one more story
let me just do it
there's no way i told the story no
god i need to start sorry guys i have
hundreds and hundreds of stories i've
told over the years
i don't know if i told them because i
were just they're in my head
i already talked about them like in my
head yeah now we got to start
transcribing the podcast yeah
because dude there's so much in my brain
like i could tell you
right now story [ __ ] 100 stories
straight would be here for two days
but it's like yo when did i tell it did
i tell it in my head
i tell it's my friend yeah am i
remembering it or did i tell them story
time because a lot of times you'll say
some [ __ ]
and you'll be like oh that should be a
story time but maybe then it never
happens
yep it was like 50 of those so
this is the uh story uh it's two hours
let me try to keep it under like
15 minutes all right here we go here we
go here we go
this story let me just tell you now made
me feel really bad
it made me feel like [ __ ] had to be done
still sucks here we go
i used to work at me and ed's it's a
pizza place in merced you guys know that
you sell weed out my pizza car
right so i always had my scale in the
car my weed in the car
i was just dropping sacks [ __ ] it i was
dropping i love
selling a [ __ ] an eighth i love
selling eights of people on my route i
make the most money off the eighth
so
i keep everything in my car because it's
not i'm not gonna miss out on money
there's no way i'm gonna
go to work and not have weed it's a
missed opportunity
i'm driving around getting paid to drive
around i can drop sacks perfect
so i open because
i'm a good worker and i start opening
from like the 10 a.m shift and up right
so i'm like the essentially the only
other person there is my manager john so
you used to work this pizza place
how about and then uh sorry sorry i feel
like
i'm already ripping that bowl damn
trying to be like goblin over here
no just [ __ ] fool's going in on it
like a [ __ ] dragon
here we go um so
i'm at work we get an order if we get an
or we open at 10.
you [ __ ] ordering pizza at 9 40.
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you just because you went
to the gym at 5 30 and you're bored
because everyone else is asleep
don't be ordering pizzas at 9 40. we
open at 10. [ __ ] you
that's worse than like a raging
alcoholic in my mind who could how many
people
because they're ordering for lunchtime
okay because they're so productive
they're at [ __ ] work
hey i'm gonna order early and they'll be
here at 11 35 because i know thomas is
always on time
[ __ ] man you know how many times i i'm
doing prep [ __ ] until 10.
the reason why i get here at [ __ ] 9
eight like damn it
i hate seeing a stack of orders but
we're not even open yet
it's the worst [ __ ] feeling anyway
i'm over here complaining about my job
i don't have anymore i get an order i'm
like
[ __ ] you five pieces [ __ ] our camera how
many pieces of stack
everything all right it's not going too
far let's do this
and on the phone i'm like
full sounds a little weird all right my
eve my manager's like it's a little
weird
and he tells me that you guys sounded
kind of off like [ __ ] okay cool
he goes remember we always have to check
for a id if you give me a check i'd
check your [ __ ] id give me fake
checks i've got
[ __ ] you how many pizzas i've eaten
because the fake check
and i take it back and like ah just put
to the side i'm like yeah
and i smash it i [ __ ] love that joe i
got to eat pizza all day it was so sick
eat pizza make cool pizza sell weed and
have a [ __ ]
we had a five-star pizza place it was a
five-star rated place
because we were baller five star rated
me and edmure said we're kind of crushed
thin crust and we had a thick dough i
know how to do everything i used to do i
used to cut the cheese blocks
with a string like a [ __ ] italian
mushroom shirt i used to cut it with the
cork handles like a 15-20 pound block of
mozzarella and then we have this other
block
oh and i would uh chop that [ __ ] with
this big-ass knife
chop this one into squares i would shred
them together and i'd make i'd make our
cheese blend with it i had to put it in
this big crusher
with this huge blade i had to sit there
with a stick
she was sick i never made dough the only
thing would take three to four days to
make our dough
so you have to be like a process like oh
day one okay cool let's start on five of
them
so by we know we're always in a row
you're growing wheat like we're always
in rotation type [ __ ]
uh anyway a guy orders pizzas
i [ __ ] take them i always check for
an id i get there i'm like uh
our pizza our pizza was like 22 dollars
a pizza back then and [ __ ] 12 years
ago 10 years ago that's a lot yeah
this is i remember the day the
commercial came out for
pizza hut 9.99 anything you want topping
and we all went
oh no
[ __ ] [ __ ] you because like that
that's when our whole store changed
everything changed we had the lower
because we had no more customers it was
unfucking i remember when it happens
like the day the stock market created
the day pizza hut's at 10.99 or ten
dollars
iron man manager went oh [ __ ] it was
weird
pizza was so twenty eight dollars were
our most expensive
that's a lot in merced with no money
yeah i mean
white people and [ __ ] joggers couples
with no kids buying our pizza that was
it
and people that worked for the city that
can afford it nobody else can afford me
that's he has a rich people [ __ ]
pizza back then
now they have [ __ ] nine dollar
[ __ ] one toppings they went down the
[ __ ] chain
because they succumbed to it yeah and
they're upset anyway
long-ass [ __ ] drag down story [ __ ]
[ __ ]
this guy's a piece of [ __ ] what a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
here we go god
driving i get to the [ __ ] apartment
complex i go oh
hell no this [ __ ] 120 dollars
these [ __ ] five pieces and [ __ ]
there's no way
you live in the apartment where i used
to live there's no way you [ __ ]
have the money go up to the apartment
it's like a
townhouse style apartments but it's a
complex so
go up to the apartment i've had fake
checks before
i know i could spot a [ __ ] give
me a fake check the second he opens the
door
he opens doors oh tail no that carpet's
mad dirty
done you don't clean your carpet you
don't ask your management to change the
carpet out you're probably not on the up
and up you're probably not
organized you know i'm automatic like oh
you can't shirtless
oh all this is weird you ordered a 10 in
the morning
[ __ ] and there's [ __ ] there was
like four to five kids i can hear them
like yeah an apartment it's a two
bedroom at most
tweakers those are your kids that's a
tweaker spot
anyway carpet mad dirty one oh mad dirty
and toys i'm like oh this is a twigger
house
and the fool comes up and the first
thing he does oh there's like five kids
jumping around on the couch and
screaming
doing kids [ __ ] the oldest one we're
like eight years old
there's five kids obviously not all his
kids there was like a [ __ ] brown kid
in there there's like a white guy
a mexican dude there was one white kid
last night you're kidding me
oh [ __ ] okay i know what's going on [ __ ]
first thing he does
before he gives me any money come get
this guys and they all rush up to me to
get the pizzas and usually i'm supposed
to get paid first but i went
you [ __ ] you know i'm not gonna say
no you're an [ __ ]
and i give a pizza to each can they all
take it back right to the couch and go
in start going in dancing around as the
guy is
[ __ ] talking to me and he goes like
this as soon as he grabs the door to
close to give me the money i went oh
what are you gonna do to me what's gonna
happen cause i know the vibe
oh it's already bad there's no way in
hell until these kids can't eat pizza
they're tweaker kids like they don't get
pizza often
and he closes the door he goes so how
much i owe you
and i go oh my god you're gonna pay me
and he reaches in as soon as i see like
a thickness
coming out of his pocket like that's
kind of wild
as soon as i see this thick-ass
checkbook come on oh
checkbook [ __ ]
man this is fake as [ __ ]
[ __ ] so he goes how much do i oh yeah
and i'll slow-mo i'm almost real i'm
like
[ __ ] this
all this is happening like damn it do
you get dinged for that does it mean
anything to you if you take
i mean yelled at or my boss is gonna be
like what the [ __ ] wrong with you my
best
your opening for me you're taking fake
checks i've taken a fake check before
because bam bam bigelow was gonna kill
me in the country
there's another story how the [ __ ] are
you supposed to know if it's a fake
check or not
like a stolen check oh the address is a
match where i can well i go
okay well i mean oh it's a [ __ ]
stolen checkbook yeah
all right a person that's on the up and
up and goes to the bank and gives them
their address
does a change of address after people
that have money in the accounts do
like like adults but tweakers no they
just found a checkbook or stole it from
some ladies purse
anyway i get i see him right in the
checkbook and he goes
how how much i'm going to give you and i
see him give me like twenty dollars
oh this is [ __ ] fake oh wait wait sorry
that check was something else
wow look how mixed up i got on my own
[ __ ]
i brought up batman bigelow that's why i
talked about the check
what an [ __ ] i just mixed up my own
story mark all right i just mixed up my
own [ __ ] story
sorry bam bam bigelow he pulled out the
checkbook all right
dude what a piece of [ __ ] see sometimes
man my brain does dumb things
i remember everything specifically
bigelow took the checkbook out and went
oh
hell no that's fake this man pulled out
a wad a stack that's right
he pulled out a stack bam bam bagel goes
you know what man i like you i'm gonna
give you
i'm gonna give you a 20 tip and that's
why oh this shit's fake as [ __ ] sorry
that's bam bam bingo in the country this
man back to the story
he closes the door how much do i owe you
man and i'm telling him slow-mo go back
to this
boom i mean i guess we could just cut
that out and pieced it together but
it's funny if you know i [ __ ] up my
own story all right
but i remember it all but yeah anyway he
pulls it out that's right and they're
off color tens do you remember the red
tens came out
like the red orange-ish looking i don't
know everyone's just
green ten dollar bills right and then
turned in like that yeah orange
on it or like that hue weird queue
almost like bronze yeah remember he
pulled out like a little stack of it and
i went oh
hell no there's no way in hell you got a
stack of money in your pocket
all the same color fake as [ __ ]
i i'm just assuming i can't believe that
[ __ ] my own story i want an
[ __ ] anyway back to the [ __ ]
story guys he pulls it out the kids are
all eating pizza doing kids [ __ ] dancing
with their [ __ ] pizza he closes the
door
oh yeah and i go [ __ ] you're going
to pay me pulls out the tens and as he's
counting a mountain goal those are
[ __ ]
fake i can see that they're [ __ ] fake
from three feet away oh hell no
i already know those are fake and
there's no way in hell i'm gonna tell
those kids they can't eat pizza
they're tweaker babies done
i'm getting [ __ ] right now and he's
like
you know what here you go man he gave me
more money i remember thinking there's
no way in hell you just gave me like ten
dollar tip
[ __ ] no [ __ ] way these are fake
and as he handed him to me i went oh
bro i feel like a towel this is not
[ __ ] the fabric of money you know
because
uh money's not paper right it's like
fabric right
i think i can't remember but i could
feel the roughness to it it was not the
same
all right i could feel the second i
graduate
i'm like okay sir thank you so much have
a great day bam put it in my pocket
and i knew i was done and i was like
[ __ ] so what the [ __ ] does me not expect
you to do
citizens arrest this [ __ ] dude that's
why
i continued ready
what a piece of [ __ ] rest of my own
[ __ ] story my god
smoke is [ __ ] my [ __ ] tweaker here
we go
as i'm driving away the cul-de-sac of
the [ __ ] i'm driving away and going damn
it
i pull up against the [ __ ] heads it's
just me and john because ricardo
the dough maker already left because
don't make it gets there like four in
the morning makes dough for five hours
leaves that's all the dough make it's
all you do because it takes [ __ ] four
days
it's just me and johnny walking i'm just
like
a little dog chewed up the [ __ ] trash
i'm like yo what's up bro
it's like what and everybody he just
goes what cause me and him were homies
back then like we were [ __ ] cool
i sold weed as mom i smoked wee with him
i got him [ __ ] passed out drunk the
first time we ever chilled and he was
like
[ __ ] boss i had to drive him home
we were friends and i'm like he knows
that look i'm like oh he goes
what go the [ __ ] order goes
don't tell me it's the [ __ ] big order
man because i took two deliveries but i
was like
a big order that's the big one the first
one this morning
what the [ __ ] man i go it's fake money
dude so fake money because he thought it
was a check i'm like
there's no way you let fake money come
by i know you drug dealing [ __ ]
you no [ __ ] money and he knew that
about you know that's so [ __ ] drugs
and packs and [ __ ]
and he goes you did not let fake money
go and go bro
and i broke this situation down i set
the story for
so the thing is man i walked in right
there's these kids dude there's [ __ ]
kids right there
and they're starting like oh hi what do
you want me to do like what the [ __ ] you
want me to tell him no
hell no [ __ ] you and i go john let's
just wait 20 minutes
wait 30 minutes then call the cops like
make sure they smash that food first
because he's going to jail anyway let
the kids smash that food
go back to playing right yeah
so he's like all right [ __ ] because we
have to report it if we get that money
it looks like we stole that [ __ ] in the
end and the end of the day count
let's say we stole five words to beat
five pieces yeah and pocketed the money
and so oh
counterfeit and if we let counterfeit
money go it looks like we did it on
purpose
he's like bro we have to call up mike i
know we have to call the cops
[ __ ] there ain't no other adults i saw
yeah i mean like there was no other
adults that i saw like [ __ ]
man it's [ __ ] dick like these kids
are
[ __ ] maybe it's better off i'm sure
they got taken out of that place
but it wasn't it wasn't like all nasty
everywhere but the carpet was [ __ ]
he tells like people to brag bike parts
and [ __ ] and work on
engines tweakers do that i'm picturing
the breaking bad when they steal the
safe
that house
seen people with motors in their living
room it's the dumbest shot everything i
[ __ ] hate tweakers i hate being
around them i [ __ ] hate it
there's so many bike parts and there's
never never a working bike
ever i'm not [ __ ] lying right i'm not
lying everybody out to the nose tweakers
i'm not a [ __ ] liar
speakers are the worst crackheads don't
own bikes they just walk around all
crazy until they smoke crack
tweakers got like [ __ ] tube tents
going on with a workshop
mm-hmm i'm telling you
anyway we wait 20 minutes call the cops
i knew it was fake i can't believe [ __ ]
my story what an [ __ ] um
the fake tens right when those red tens
those orange-ish looking ones bronze
around that time cops come john's
outside talking to him and then he looks
in
it's a glass window i can see him i'm
like that stay away from my car
my car's out there with a [ __ ]
halloween in the trunk
right in front of the building like
y'all stay away from the car that's all
i keep thinking like
there's a scale and there's there's
maintenance
to go cheese and pepper cups where i put
my weed in i usually sell eight since
you're like
[ __ ] put them in a cup i don't use
bags yeah [ __ ] yeah
and uh y'all stay away from my [ __ ]
and the cops are standing there just
talking and i see them all look in i'm
like
why what no like
was that look you guys didn't smell
everything collectively ago
definitely somebody in there has weed so
they all look in i'm like
oh hell no what does that look and john
comes in with him he walks in with a cob
like
oh no and they break it down to me that
i have to go with them
sorry i know i'm talking you can tell a
story i gotta remember i gotta talk to
the [ __ ] camera what an [ __ ]
sorry camera sorry guys
[ __ ] it walks in the c yeah it's more
like story time there you go
damn it marty it's so odd not been a
while
i know i know i'm sorry this episode's
[ __ ] everywhere here we go
john walks in with the [ __ ] two cops
two cops come in
they break it down and explain to me
that i have to go with them
ready i have to go with them
and point out the guy and make sure
that's him before they can make an
arrest because if not
it's just me saying marty's
you know wife gave me counterfeit money
and they go arrest her
like no [ __ ] i'm just gonna arrest
somebody based on that but they believed
this we had the money but i had to go
point out the guy and make sure that was
him or they're just gonna go and pick up
a guy that's at that apartment
or something so i had to go with them
that's probably a pretty bad example
actually
i just went all off my brain i had to go
with them
they tell me to go point out the guy you
know how many hard it was not to say to
go finger the guy and it sounds so
terrible
i was four times i went point out the
guy because i was going yeah
that's what i was thinking but like you
have to come with us and point them out
like are you kidding me an active guy
selling packs with a scale and
[ __ ] in the trunk of the car parked
next to the cop car
and i'm looking at john like i don't
want to say no in front of the cops be a
dick and like why doesn't the pizza guy
want to come with us where do you got to
hide what's the big deal
but i also didn't want to go like this
john what the [ __ ] man
like cover my [ __ ] i couldn't and he's
like my friends i'm looking at him like
yeah i'll go man that's fine no totally
cool i'm looking at john like
honestly he's looking at me like [ __ ]
i'm so sorry you have to go in the cops
right now like all right
let's go what happens what do you think
happens when i get outside
when you get outside his apartment no
when i get outside the meeting has to
get in the car
what happens if you have to ride with
the cops they're pushing in the back
i never in the back of a cop car okay
[Laughter]
i didn't like driving through town back
of a cop car i didn't like driving
through the back
of a cop car in a small town and i kept
waiting for my grandma to walk just
pull up like what the [ __ ] my
grandmother the mexican like
yeah i knew something was gonna happen
like you know i saw thomas in the back
of a cop car
what do you mean you saw thomas in the
back cop car you just said he's gonna
sell me five packs
yeah not cool a bunch of different
reasons you see what i'm saying like
what do you mean you saw him in the cop
car yeah
that was weird did you know cop cars the
backs are super slick
i was sliding the [ __ ] yeah with
plastic yeah they're plastic i had me
and ed's work khakis on
your [ __ ] uh it was not fun
and they're like making small talk with
me as i'm driving over there the whole
time like this in the back just
being next to you guys they turn around
to talk
yeah yeah no no yeah i work being ads
[ __ ] you guys man why are you gonna brew
in this right now i was like [ __ ] do you
want me to go can you just go arrest him
[ __ ] bring a picture of him yeah it's
the tweaker up there
yeah the tweaker guy no shirt
yeah he had no [ __ ] shirt on but when
they got him he had a red shirt on
or orangish red shirt it was all [ __ ]
up i just remember seeing a guy with no
shirt damn
what's going on with me today anyway
guys
we pull up to the [ __ ] cul-de-sac we
pull up to the cold side they're
explaining to me like it's a mission
so what you're gonna do we're gonna park
in the mill street right we're going to
park down a couple houses down so he
doesn't see you
he knows who delivered the pizza the fat
mexican kid
go to me and ed's what's that messy kids
well not that one
it's that guy the one that i recognized
so i'm like yo he knows who is
out here going ham and i'm the whole
time like
you want me to do what
i have to tell on this man right now and
point my fingers they're putting a wire
on you bro i felt
so like this goes against everything i
believe in guys
but i also can't go [ __ ] you guys i
ain't doing that [ __ ] why is the pizza
guy
nice kid that's going to college telling
us nah [ __ ] you i ain't pointing
i'm not stitching on him i had to play
the part
and playing the part mean i had to go
and [ __ ] point this man out
you know a conflict that was i'm not
like
i can't tell him like bro so packs i
can't be [ __ ] having this out here
[ __ ]
what do you say to me that's the code
yeah but i couldn't tell the cops that
i was [ __ ] pissed he's explaining to
me you're in the bag you got a point
where a couple of
houses down and then he goes on the walk
he's talking he goes all right bring him
out
and i can see the guy sitting he's put
two cops standing next to him right in
front of the apartment it was the
apartment right in front of the
cul-de-sac circle part and then the
complex started it was bam right there
the bottom floor there was a top floor
like a townhouse style
it was the second one over and he'd
bring him out
and i could tell it's him i could see
him that's the same [ __ ] dude
i don't know he got a shirt but i know
it's the same guy i could see him
and they bring him out he's like oh
looking down like dude this
is trash who else is there to watch
these kids
it's the first thing i kept thinking and
the second thing i kept thinking was
like
am i really doing this here right now
i'm really just telling on somebody
actively selling packs this is [ __ ]
stupid and
anyway [ __ ] [ __ ] anyway
he's the [ __ ] [ __ ] what do you
think
all these things are going through my
head like you know what if someone does
this to you
like that's the way i see selling
[ __ ] dropping packs off in duffel bag
over there like you don't do that
but i had to play the part i work at the
yeah it's not like you're doing this
like the rich guy
nice pete's spot a lot of the sheriffs
come in there to [ __ ] eat
they're the ones that can afford it they
have jobs
you know stay with the city so
i had to play the part and i remember
i'm sitting there like oh yeah and
internally like
yo get the [ __ ] out of the car oh yeah
you can't [ __ ] open the door
sick i'm here i'm here and i can't say
no or else they're gonna be like why
anyway i know i'm repeating myself they
bring him out and i go yep that's him
they go are you sure that's him
yeah man that's the guy i could see him
from here
he goes all right and you walk down he's
okay all right we're good i'll
bring him in and then you start putting
him in the car i'm like yo that was
crazy how fast that was like that man's
life's changed counterfeiting money
like where they're not i don't know
where he got the fake money but he's
trying to buy [ __ ] with fake money you
are in trouble you know he's got a
[ __ ] pookie pipe
you know he's got a [ __ ] felony you
know he's got a [ __ ] war something
stupid or a drug offense
i [ __ ] it i was i was not happy i'm
not done
you ready for this after the whole spiel
of the guy going oh we're gonna go a
couple feet back
all right ready go they don't want you
to see like he was like all [ __ ]
sergeant about it
we want him to see you and identify you
later on in life i'm like
okay he knows where it's at we're moving
on your witness protection program
that's pretty much how you were saying
like
so we're gonna keep you back here okay
you know sit over lean over sit behind
me and then you lean over and you'll
tell me they're used to dealing with
game banger [ __ ] this is true
true true delivery preacher delivery
[ __ ]
anyway like yo all that talk
and the guy starts driving to the
cul-de-sac to flip a [ __ ] to leave
[Laughter]
marty we're [ __ ] houses down the
house is down this long-ass cul-de-sac
house is down way down parked like
[ __ ] four to five
i mean three to four houses down which
is pretty far and then the apartment
complex starts
the man starts after the whole [ __ ]
army sergeant [ __ ]
the driver starts driving to the
cul-de-sac toward the man in the car
getting in the car
starts driving to him to him and i'm
like oh maybe he's flipping right here
oh maybe he's going
nah he's not going to keep going he's
still driving and i go
uh aren't you supposed to not have me
over there he goes oh
and he starts reversing all the way back
jesus christ
oh that's the noise she gave me after
that whole spiel like we need to not
identify you later on
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
if i didn't say nothing that was it you
would have just drove right up to the
man me parked as he flipped it like
i [ __ ] saw her name tag yeah
[Music]
no dude so he flipped it
oh no he reversed all the way back even
though he could you know just
pull into the driveway to your right
uh-huh he's like
turning that driveway and then just you
know austin powers out of here
no i think i reversed all the way back
looking straight at my face
i just i'm trying to like not make eye
contact you guys are reversing i'm like
oh it's weird
i went back to work told john the entire
thing
and i lived the rest of my life uh-huh
that was it
i'm sorry guy no i i actually don't feel
bad for that piece of [ __ ] cause april
got wrapped up in some [ __ ] like that
right when i first met her
oh yeah i remember you told me her
friend's boyfriend
was like buying pizzas with a fake
credit card
to a hotel room that they were like
staying at for the night and she had
signed for the room
she didn't know he had like stolen
credit cards or whatever and then
that's what happened yeah she went to
[ __ ] jail for that [ __ ]
for like a night she signed for the room
her and her friend her friend ends up
bringing the boyfriend who ends up
ordering pizzas and [ __ ]
stolen credit cards do you imagine that
he was like yeah go ahead and order food
full
you go to jail because what they did
pissed yeah real bad i was done done
yeah yo uh marty what the [ __ ] is the
name of this episode
[Music]
yo for real what's the name of this i
don't know we're going to figure that
one out
uh i wish you could click on titles they
just say like a good four seconds or
something uh-huh here's some good
suggestions
no like click on the title like of
youtube
it just says click here and instead of
like uh
tales from the hood it's just yeah fool
shut up [ __ ] fool
that's no that's the title just it's a
it's an audio
title you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
or like plays a little gif
uh-huh i just wish we could actually
title the [ __ ] we want to really title
it without youtube getting butt hurt
yeah youtube likes to uh adult language
they get mad like to
limit our ads or sometimes age restrict
if our titles are a little
they send us an email letting us know
like your title was profane or had
profanity in it
oh and then just regular english words
yeah all right [ __ ] okay so we're trying
to be a little
ease around it so youtube doesn't get
mad at us i mean we like youtube a lot
so we don't want him to get pissed dude
that was a long episode marty
we talked about a lot of stuff and i
don't remember [ __ ] 10
of it that's how it usually goes yeah
okay maybe that's what it is i'm just
not used to that's the formula yeah okay
i'm only a joint and a half deep i'm
[ __ ] high
so did you bake up any of those cookies
yet
no i'm doing the video oh yeah
that's right guys ready
cosmic edibles is a vegan cookie company
they're
vegan medicated cookies i really [ __ ]
with them i ate them from dtpg from og
shop
i started liking them a couple months
ago we talked
and we were like yeah let's make a
dopaziola version like a collaboration
topaziola
because they're vegan and i
automatically cool
[ __ ] yeah thank you i can actually eat
these edibles and they're pop as [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] bomb i forget they're
medicated i just smashed a pack
i smashed a pack while i was cleaning up
the other day for getting other
medicated cookies and ate the whole
[ __ ] pack
anyway um we started working on a little
collaboration and their thing is you
know california law 100 milligrams
edibles you can't go past that
so they have a little tube of cookies
and they're like 10 cookies or 10
milligrams each right
100 milligrams cool that's the law
right so i said hey how can we like you
know make it stronger
because i might do a dopamine version i
i would like it to be more than 10
milligrams a cookie
no i mean that's fine but first you
don't have to sit and eat a whole giant
batch of [ __ ] cookies to feel
i mean you know what i mean like mom is
funny very very good all right bad point
but yes for some people don't want to i
was like how can we make it like
stronger and they go we legally can't
i go [ __ ] all right i think so what
about like one big cookie and going
that's what i mean that's what i was
that's bomb
and they go okay how about this how
about instead of making one big cookie
because they have like their proprietary
i think
packaging as like a sick ass tube
twist.sick
like yo we can't just you know how much
it costs to make
just a specific batch of they're a big
like you see what i'm saying doesn't
work that way in production
it's like yo what if we did something
like this what if you made
medicated cookie dough and you take home
and you make your own [ __ ] maybe you
make maybe
half of it maybe make ten tens or ten a
hundred or whatever you want to do
basically we said leave it up to the
customer to tell what
to say what their night is going to be
you know what i mean
so what we did guys is we made a
dopaziola
the dopest dough that's what it's called
the dopest dough mm-hmm
dope is the old time cosmic edibles they
just dropped live
monday they just dropped a couple days
ago legally in stores so we have a legal
edible with our [ __ ] name on it says
dope is yellow on it bam
dopes yellow times cosmic it says the
dope is dough
monday as in like yesterday uh when's
the stores yeah
monday damn i didn't realize that yeah
dropping stores
yeah i when i was there filming to get
my batch like to i want to do a video of
it to show you uh youtube like dobasilla
channel
as i was doing it they were packing up
the first order
this place called packwood or pacquille
or some
they were the first pair of people to
order and i'm like yo the first order's
going out as i'm here like
nice [ __ ] yeah cool and um yeah we have
our own [ __ ] medicated
can people order it online or just on
shops no it's just in shops uh
cosmic edibles so if your local
dispenser doesn't have it tell them
they're [ __ ] up
it's medicated take home cookie dough
i've never heard of that before i love
that
well i mean it's pretty [ __ ] cool and
it's vegan
so it doesn't [ __ ] go bad in certain
aspects like
you can eat the dough there's no like
egg or
raw milk rum egg or anything yeah you
can just eat the dough i was going to
say fast forward to me just shoving the
dough on my face
yeah dude so you guys want to hear what
the cookie is
it's marshmallows sprinkles
and i think it was chocolate chips nice
it sounds like yo what
about like all together oh you wanna
you know throw a bunch of [ __ ] together
yeah like what if we did him
oh he goes yeah we can do that for real
like i need to watch the office but when
he's getting on pretzel day could we
just do like a little bit of all
the works yes that's me oh my god
every email what so yeah it's like a
bright colorful ass
cookie i ate i made some and ate it
you know they're not i don't give a [ __ ]
it has my name on it now those are
[ __ ] great mm-hmm they're
so we're gonna have to have some in here
ready for the guests when they come in
that's not even a bad idea what if we
got a [ __ ]
easy bake of it
that'd be sick that'd be sick i'm gonna
look on ebay tonight for an easy makeup
cookies on the table oh my by the way
these are
medicated cookies there's a dough balls
you can eat those dough balls
one other podcast has done that it's not
a bad idea
i'm out of it
i like that yo for all you
always study fans out there remember
when charlie and mac aren't really
hanging out
and charlie and danny devito go to the
restaurant at the same time that
uh glenn howerton and rob or or mac why
do i say their real names
remember when charlie and frank are in
the restaurant
and the other side of the restaurant
glenn and uh mac are there
and then when charlie and mack finally
connect eyes
that's when you said have a plate of
cookie that's what i did right now
yeah we have those moments a lot
[Laughter]
that's what we're gonna do oh my [ __ ]
god
that's what we're gonna do oh my god
yeah that's so smart we're trying to
step our [ __ ] up for the guests
we started with the silent fan and we're
rolling out more luxuries
got the silent fan going on you know we
got working water
running water might get a fridge goblin
got the [ __ ]
[Music]
christmas satchel of [ __ ]
concentrates and [ __ ]
we're elevating yo what's happening we
just talked for two and a half hours
how about can we just mention that that
little photo shoot that we did
and i was trying to like emerge yeah
great
the photos came out great so good we
gotta take pictures of these [ __ ]
bags
we gotta go out and do it yeah for real
i really really really need it
by the way push trees i've been waiting
for [ __ ]
episode three while scamming through
skimming through the episodes to find
out if i talk about that story i told
you
i talked about the bags and you're like
i'm just surprised that like you
they look they're what you want the
first time you know they're going to be
here soon
four and a half months ago yeah so we're
going to lose three two months before
that i've been waiting for these bags
for like five
this is your biggest order ever anything
ever i've never spent more money in my
whole [ __ ] life
on anything in life maybe the car uh-huh
because you got i don't know if you want
to talk about all this
about all the different things that are
going to be dropping on push charges oh
yeah that's fine um
for push trees dude we have the bags
that are
going to be live this this this episode
comes out monday
so the bags actually come out in this
time inception
that came out a couple days ago but
realistically they come out friday the
bags are alive
bags are live that's just confused and
[ __ ] [ __ ] fall asleep
we got backpacks little shoulder bags
and duffel bags
i try to base it off like a louis
vuitton bag i really like so i try to
make it a little more
it's all vegan leather by the way vegan
leather i know what the [ __ ] is that
i don't know [ __ ] just not made
out of the plants i mean animals right
this is from almonds and [ __ ] [ __ ]
almond leather [ __ ] it's fruit
strip
it's fruit stripe it's jackfruit it's
jackfruit backpacks
yes here we go backpacks all right
there's
one line uh they all match and the other
one is more
low-key because one's very like little
like high-class look they look designer
as [ __ ] they were expensive and then the
other ones are for
fools that are like more low-key maybe
there's some packs in the bag or
something
anyway i love everything love them all
they came out
uh we got some hats dropping best hats
i've ever seen
i've produced like 10 hats best hats
we've had
these are [ __ ] baller they got their
own individual
stamp clamps in the back with a logo on
oh my god
are you talking about the dad hat says
are you talking about the beanies all of
it oh yeah we got beanies coming out too
i try to do a whole different look
nothing is different than anything
you've done
yeah everything looks
nothing i've done but i'm happy that
you're also bringing out a bunch of like
og
classic items too for the first time
like just with the
the orange yes for sure oh the clothes
so we have a clothing drop too
first time we've ever done just branding
you know usually it's
art artwork literal [ __ ] art pieces i
put on shirts
like the literal art pieces that we put
on shirts with a [ __ ] frame their
hearts
they look like [ __ ] hand painting and
usually just something wild or loud or
something that makes people walk by and
go
what the [ __ ] is that you know how many
times i get that go
nice and i go oh yeah oh yeah which one
is it
because i i always forget you know when
people go nice sharing i go
thanks man because sometimes it's not
even though my own shirt it's not even
pushed tree shingle
like last night somebody standing i was
like oh it was mike tyson mm-hmm beating
about a bunch of cop in the face
like nice sure i go oh yeah my taste
cherry
and uh this is the first time we ever
did it it's like push trees
logo push trees words hits just like
very not loud you can wear it
[ __ ] anywhere sweats never made sweat
we're making shorts
wearing sweats we have the hats coming
out we got hella shirts
sweaters oh my god there's two [ __ ]
boxes of socks right there
i haven't put on the site yet first time
we've ever made socks with packaging so
nice
dude everything is i didn't even want to
wear them
these are nice collectors
um yeah dude we've never made this much
stuff ever
probably got dab rigs coming like a
heady
dope dab i don't know nothing about that
not the bones we're making
under push trees
[Music]
idab glass is going to make them for us
um but yeah that's the little update man
we have this emotion i've ever [ __ ]
done in my life me and rosie
we've been doing so much man [ __ ] ton of
boxes in here right now
i need more shells we already mentioned
dope's usual dot store
we have it have we not no we said ooh
and we got the new sweater
and the back you can't see because i
can't turn looks a little something like
this
yeah so check it out dope is dope as
usual dot store
click the link it'll be linked in the
description of the video
if you're on spotify no matter
description of the video
that's one of the best ways to support
the podcast period yes that
or what you say tell a friend exactly
the biggest one you can do because
that's kind of telling a friend you're
like oh rocking the gear yeah you're
right you're right
but i remember you told me that way like
i've been thinking about it a lot
that is the best way to support you know
if you don't have to spend anything
watching is great tell a friend too like
yo have you seen this i watch this
podcast
check it out if you don't like it cool
great you know i mean like
unless you don't like ranting you
probably like it
if you don't need a cool place to
[ __ ] hang out mondays whatever
something yo this episode marty i think
i say that every [ __ ] time like this
[ __ ] episode is everywhere but it
truly is everywhere
and uh for everyone in the chat live
chat right now what's up
i see you guys every [ __ ] week thank
you
um i think that's it man i i hate all my
notes
hit everything i think that's it oh yeah
i feel good about it
super grateful man i'm grateful to be a
part of this and this whole time frame
that we're in and everybody supporting
the show and people coming on the show
and everything rolling out as we planned
just when it was all a thought
it's weird to see it coming together
coming to fruition
but to all the kids that are messaging
us and all the dms and [ __ ] like this is
what it looks like to do something
self-made and uh
to flip and to parlay and there's no
companies front none of this
you know so this is what it appears to
be it doesn't happen a lot in podcasting
there's no
big celebrity endorsement no big checks
no big nothing this [ __ ] is authentic
and if
it's [ __ ] it's happening so quick yeah
that
man it feels amazing sometimes you got
to push all your chips in and
truly yeah for real
so much [ __ ] went into this man for
just us
literally just us rosie deanna helping
mm-hmm
yeah i think about it when i look at the
other shows like god damn this is like a
10-man operation
oh i always think about it what if we
had you just talking
bringing up [ __ ] on the camera i mean on
the computer and we had one two
two people manning everything yeah
that'd be a luxury
yeah that'd be nice right now marty's
playing [ __ ] quarterback and wide
receivers
i was trying to talk to him as he was
changing the cameras i forgot that he
was
not over there man so yes
yeah it is weird looking at it and
seeing it and when you stand like new
posts or new thumb
every time you send me the new thumb the
newest thumbnail for like the gas i go
oh [ __ ] yeah
it's happening for me it's weird too
because i watched i watched this happen
before
growing up listening to rogan i've seen
this all kind of transpire when we had
goblin on i was like damn that was when
like rogan
introduced joey diaz to the world it
really was
the way that felt in this little chapter
that we're in now of like kevin
introducing people to og
introducing people to yes to all these
people they might not know and we're not
just going after the big names that we
can find but we want to like
the names are cool yeah if we want to
talk to them [ __ ] yeah exactly
like you know how many [ __ ] celebrity
giant youtuber and [ __ ]
tick-tock yeah exactly some [ __ ]
comedian or whatever just
like for sure we could do that but [ __ ]
off
no hell no yeah that's that's one thing
i can
adamantly say is we're not going to have
any [ __ ] guests or any [ __ ]
sponsors that the
ship has sailed we've already stood up
on that
never we stood up on we we passed on a
deal earlier today because they didn't
have any vegan options that's how
authentic it is
i couldn't i couldn't do they're like
hey guys here's a check we want to give
it to you
they even followed up guys we're trying
to give you guys a check
i know i feel bad i i do feel bad i do
but it's like we can't endorse it if
thomas can't [ __ ] understand that
then yeah probably shouldn't be over
here yeah
make some vegan [ __ ] man [ __ ] yeah so
that's that's uh
that's you know our commitment to the
fans for sure you guys
keep supporting us and showing us love
just be it with the views with the
apparel with the comments telling a
friend
whatever you know it all helps
truly thank you guys it is weird
it's weird seeing it you know i'm just
over here
[ __ ] ice cube and friday two in the
back of
pinkie's record shot
nice you were talking i'm just over here
yo what's happening to me man crazy this
would be stronger
i feel like dayday and craig often on
the show like it's not that far off
yo ice cube come chill smoke weed we'll
[ __ ] get fat burger to
give us some fat burgers we'll hear
smoke weed and talk about
not really there i don't know i was
kidding my kids
no they love that [ __ ] new generation
that's that's what that's the
that's how they know him yeah that's an
ice cube they know yeah 21 gem street
ice cube
we don't know [ __ ] the points that's an
ice cube which
is fine i was making more money now yeah
i mean
[ __ ] if tomorrow you told me
hey man i'll give you like 30 mil a year
if you just stop [ __ ] with the wheat
i will smoke you tonight i will see you
as i get to my house
uh i don't smoke weed on the podcast
anymore we are sellout
i am it took 30 mil
[Laughter]
yeah if you told me stop smoking weed
for 30 mil you need a dick i'm gonna
smoke me forever no
but if you're like no stop you know
doing wii videos buddy
can i help other people do weed videos
yeah i won't
be the biggest piece of [ __ ] of all time
for passing up that money
that's generational money yeah
but that's also podcasting money i mean
[ __ ] rogan set a whole new precedent
in the world and broadcasting that's
true
it broadcasts not even podcast that's
broadcast money yeah
that's that howard stern money that came
over and uh
podcasting so yeah if you guys are
always asking what's it
what would it take you to stop doing wee
videos 30 million dollars
cut the check what would it take to stop
smoking weed nothing i would not stop
smoking weed
i love it too much yeah he means that
[ __ ] yeah it's just too fun
breaking dating moments you can't do
that
oh [ __ ] what i look like right now
[ __ ] [ __ ] what it look like right
now full time
what a difference and in my head i go yo
bro what are you
doing right now what are these movements
like oh just chilling
uh-huh i'm sorry
um sorry guys for everyone at home
doesn't know what just happened
it's turning youtube doing something for
some form of
interpretive dance
i don't know what to call it jesus
christ oh man
jesus christ i'm sorry i can only
imagine what my neighbors think of me i
was considering that this morning they
got to think i'm such a [ __ ] psycho
like is the ass cracker don't know this
was out there coughing up all [ __ ]
long
yeah i don't know why but
every time marty buys me and i just
happen to facetime him
anytime the camera's down
he's outside i'm like oh he's walking to
his front of his house to get this wheel
delivered
and every time oh thank you so much sir
and then you walk back oh just by weed
it took me like five times to realize
that like now i know the camera's
pointed up you just walk like hold on
one second
i just happen to catch him when he's out
the guys outside like how many times now
it's been a few it's been a [ __ ] long
i'm gonna say over eight times
at least so random yeah every time i
call you you don't have headphones on
something else is happening uh-huh
yeah i'm always editing on something
you're talking [ __ ] to april
yeah you always go i'm dealing with
these [ __ ] kids who says that a lot
deal with these [ __ ] kids
[ __ ] marty says uh they're always damn
psychos over here
that's another one of psychos over here
all right he's got one [ __ ] in
my ears i'm talking about one
[ __ ] thing
another [ __ ] talking about
another [ __ ] thing panned down
to the dog whining at me and [ __ ]
yeah i just found out he sits at your
feet every day i had no idea until
three days ago yeah yo marty we're
having a facetime conversation at this
point
i'm sorry guys i'm sorry we do this [ __ ]
[ __ ] four times a day
i'm very sorry that's everything in the
podcast let's
end this party all right we're over here
just talking about nothing
which is fine oh don't scare the [ __ ]
out of me again
oh i even stopped and thought it was my
voice like cracking
ugh hey man
yeah we're going to get him to here
we're going to have emery go
what would you say yeah right to a guest
that's true because well we're going to
have josh on next week nobody tell them
nobody tell them as you say it on the
podcast
yeah we're just saying how funny be we
get deep into mushrooms and mayhem part
two
and i got loaded up on the soundboard my
little daughter
i don't hear anything oh
we could play that well he'd lose i
think he'd forget i think he's freaking
out
you have to talk to jake beforehand to
his son like yo go with it
uh-huh go like dad what yeah you don't
hear
what oh my god do it throughout the
podcast
yo everybody let's collectively keep a
secret
for real let's see if we can go a full
week
without you guys [ __ ] this up okay
josh watching this live we're josh
watching this
ass end of the episode
[Laughter]
he just dudes it at 2 45
you know what nobody watched the end of
this week's episode josh was just a
power fan
sat through it all all right guys guys
i've watched every minute of every
episode
always in every live and i'm [ __ ]
like oh [ __ ] you comment on everything
yo i'm sorry we're just dragging it on
anyway let's collectively keep a secret
not tell josh wolf about this please
let's see if we can [ __ ] with him we
made some mushrooms i got a bunch of
mushrooms
i don't mean a bunch all right i have a
bunch of mushrooms for myself to eat
that rose it cooks with uh yes
we probably only have like a half ounce
of those style of mushrooms they're
legal now
actually though right i know but i don't
want people thinking i have helipacks
and mushrooms i have
literally a mushroom
this much mushrooms all right don't be
[ __ ] kicking my door in [ __ ] i
don't [ __ ] sell drugs somewhere
nor do i have mass amounts of weight
that is out
all right we gotta we gotta get out of
here i'm so sorry
[Music]
oh see i can't even do it i have a story
about that song i can't even get into it
it's too much [ __ ] it when i went to
clackamas the first day of school you
know how they play
music or between classes or you know
between class periods of school
do they play music where you get
announcements to the hallway
this you know what i mean at school that
song plays
every [ __ ] period break
that's torture everything marty every
vouch for me anybody that went to
clackamas high anybody that's ever been
to clackamas high
what song do they play today anybody
please
please
clack a miss organ i went to that school
my first day
went [ __ ] no [ __ ] way
everybody's got a cell phone
this is [ __ ] insane like i was
shocked there's no way
there's no way that was just a fluke
maybe it was like to cheer everybody up
come [ __ ] third period they're still
playing the [ __ ] stuff
my cousin adrian went to that school my
stepbrother mark my
little brother martin i think he went to
that school
i don't remember but god damn it
adrian went he can vouch for me he
[ __ ] vouched for me [ __ ] that [ __ ]
it was weird anyway see he brought up
that damn song
oh because i started singing that
[ __ ] stupid other song
for no reason ah i'm sorry
i gotta we gotta get out of here owners
kicking us the [ __ ] out of here
all right guys thank you so much for
listening to this [ __ ]
[ __ ] rant for this past 20 minutes
oh my god
jesus christ that's why they like the
solo apps
and marty's so official he don't even
say episodes no more he says epps now
you know why because it's [ __ ] faster
more efficient you get more done health
it's because we're talking about friday
i got mic apps on the mind i think
that's what would be what it is
or maybe it's my thing maybe it's the
thing i said you just want to be
efficient
i'm [ __ ] high i have another huge i
haven't i know yeah i was like damn you
rolled up a couple of them
another joint over here i'm done i'm
done i'm done what time is it marty
it is 12 30 in the [ __ ] morning all
right at least we don't have a brand new
sponsor to do ad read for that's fine
i have to be back in this warehouse in
nine hours
to film for nine hours i have two big
three videos to film
let's do it okay ah
guys thank you so much for watching
thank you for hanging out with us thank
you for
putting up with this i should have said
thanks for putting up with this
this whole [ __ ] hitting beavs and
butthead noises when it's supposed to be
horns yeah
thank you that was cut too short i don't
know
i'm trying to do it but it's not doing
it like that i got to fix it yeah you
got it
figuring it out during the episode look
at my dj skills now
yeah all right guys spent two hours and
54 minutes so [ __ ] off
thank you so much for watching thank you
for hanging out marty thank you for
[ __ ] putting up with this marty's
whole family's out of town right now
so he's over there just getting work
done and [ __ ] it's crazy
seriously so marty's about to go home
that's why you're like oh 12 30. it's
all right
i'm gonna take care of no [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i'm on vacation oh man
on vacation while working the whole
[ __ ] time don't stop but it's all
good
thank you for uh hanging out this long
it's been three hours rosie's probably
[ __ ] wondering what's going on
it's [ __ ] one in the morning oh
that's why i'm like a kid when the kid
starts getting [ __ ] delirious and
starts talking about nothing
that's me i think that's why i'm [ __ ]
tired something i'm gonna talk about
some
[ __ ] i was supposed to end this [ __ ]
five minutes ago
guys thank you so much for watching this
has been episode 23. the title is i have
no [ __ ] clue
thank you for hanging out with us this
is not a guest episode so
we just we gotta tighten it up son
we said hour and a half tops maurice 300
hours to you okay here we go
guys thank you so much for watching
appreciate it so much thank you for
listening this to us rant i might have
gotten a little bit too high today and i
didn't eat food
that's what the problem is i didn't eat
today what an ass that's what does it
every three hour episode i drink some
juice i know huh
i drink some juice only and took a b12
pill
i'm out of here i'm telling these guys
about my [ __ ] day like i'm 70.
i have i'm not gonna even get into it
let's just stop thank you guys so much
for watching this has been the dope
usual podcast once again we have no idea
what the title is
guys thank you so much for hanging out
with us we're here to talk about life
problems drugs accomplishments and
everything in between
today was a bunch of everything in
between and life
i think there's a little bit of drugs
involved but there always are a little
bit of drugs in
guys thank you so much for watching for
marty and i we appreciate you
thank you so much this has been dope as
usual podcast have a dope ass day
uh if you're on youtube don't forget to
drop a [ __ ] like and stuff if
you're in the chat
still shout out to you thank you to
everybody in the chat
have a dope ass day even when i said
we're done i still
kept talking it's your bills sweater
it makes me want to keep going
yo i'm [ __ ] high
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]